Hi guys, and welcome to the course on introduction
to ASP dotnet core 3.1. My name is Megan and I
will be our instructor on this introductory
course, we will understand the basics of
ASP dotnet core, the reason behind its evolution
followed by the new files and folder structure
that have been introduced. Once we understand
that, then we will take a look at new concepts
like middleware, routing, tag helpers, Razor
syntax, and much more. Now, with ASP. NET Core,
there are two ways to build a web application.
First approach is MVC application. And the second
approach is razor pages application. We will
be building projects in both the technologies
to understand how the basics work. Both the
projects will be built with a basic crud website,
which stands for create, read, update and
delete functionality. So we will understand
how to connect with database and playing with
Entity Framework in our ASP dotnet core web
application. Now, before we start, there are some
prerequisites that you should be familiar with,
I would say about three months of coding in
C sharp and familiarity with basic SQL will
be sufficient. Also, if you're stuck with the
course, my code will be published on GitHub
repository. So you can always follow along with
each lecture. And if there is something which
still does not make sense for you, you can always
raise a question, and I will be happy to answer
that. But the first approach you should take
is compare your code with my version on GitHub,
and try to identify the differences. This way, you
will try to identify the errors yourself. Now this
would be a basic course on ASP dotnet core, but
it will give you have a solid foundation before
you dive into deeper and complex courses. At
the end if you are interested in more detail,
and in depth courses, I have courses on both MVC
as well as razor pages with ASP dotnet core. And I
will also show you how you can enroll into those
courses for the lowest price. That being said,
let's get started on this exciting journey to
explore the basics of ASP dotnet core. And I
will see you in the next video. In this course,
we'll be building two projects, first will be
a simple Razer project. And second one will be
our main project which will use MVC. So let me
demo the first project that we'll be building.
It's a simple book list raiser project in which
if you select the book tab, it will display a
list of all of the books. Now here in the list,
you can see two types of tables. That is because
at the end, here we are using data tables, which
makes call of API. On top here we have a simple
table using th en tr tags here, when you create
a book, if you try to enter without anything, we
have validations once you enter the details to
create a new book, and you hit the Create button,
it creates the book and displays in both places.
here when we use data tables, if we click Edit
here, and if we change something that will make
it a capital W and updated, there you go, you can
see it is updated. If you try to delete anything,
it will display a suite alert to you. That being
said, we have multiple ways. As I was saying
before, in the Create new book, you will see a
new page called create. But if you go to absurd,
it will be the absurd page. And that will be the
same page that we'll use to edit. If we go right
here. You see it's absurd. And if you look right
here, it will be again an added page. So this is
more of a simplified view. And then at bottom,
what we see is more of an advanced view. That
being said, we are performing CRUD operations
on our book. But this project is not just that,
we'll be learning razor pages and how page model
and page view comes into the picture. So even
though this is a small project for crud operation,
that is lots of basic functionalities and basic
fine overview that you need to understand. That
being said, let's take a look at the demo of
our final project, which is way more advanced
than what you see right here. In this video,
let me walk you through the small project that we
will build using MVC. This will be a very basic
project to create CRUD operations on book list.
So right here, if you go on book list, we will
be using data tables to display all of the list
from the database. You can add a new book here,
you can fill in the details. But let's say if
you do not enter a name, we see validations that
have been enforced here. That being said, you can
create a book and once it is created, you can edit
any of the details here. And you can also delete
book. When you delete we have nice alerts that you
can display here. And once it is successfully
deleted, you will also see nice notifications.
So this is a great project to get started with
the MVC journey and learn what ASP dotnet core
has to offer. In this video, I want to give you
a small introduction on ASP dotnet evolution.
asp dotnet core introduces probably the biggest
shift the platform has experienced so far,
but let's take a look at how it has evolved over
time. In 1996, Microsoft released framework known
as ASP, which stands for active Server Pages, or
classic ASP. With classic ASP Microsoft made it
possible to have server side scripting to dynamic
web pages. The biggest revolution came when
Microsoft released dotnet framework. Microsoft
introduced ASP. NET webforms in 2002. This made
creation of web page similar to the creation
of Windows form. There are a few downsides with
web forms, web forms, tried to make stateless web
stateful. And in order to do that, it had to make
lots of changes to make sure web pages retain
their state or their values automatically. View
states contained those values, and that resulted
in a lot of data being generated and transferred
with each request. Sometimes even if it was
not required. webforms was the first version
to introduce code behind code behind is good, but
it makes testing difficult. Because in one line,
we are reading from the database, and in the next
line, we are updating the UI. Another common issue
was page life cycle. When requesting the page,
number of events were getting fired. Getting to
know all of these events was quite easy to get
it wrong. Although there were a few downsides,
web forms were generally successful to get site
up and running quickly. Couple of years later,
in 2009, Microsoft released the first version
of ASP NET MVC, and they tried to overcome most
of the problems with webforms. It had emphasis
on separation of concern. MVC code is typically
much easier to write unit test for MVC was the
first edition where they released it as open
source. Now a lot of developers did not like MVC
framework because it had its own flaws. When it
was created. It was built on top of the components
already created for web forms, because of which it
was closely tied to system dot web, which was tied
to IIS and eventually windows. On the other hand,
web is evolving quickly. And hence Microsoft had
to keep MVC with everything that was changing.
Also, MVC was built before cloud came into the big
picture. Even though a lot of MVC applications are
still running on cloud, but it is still not build
with cloud in mind. Finally, in June of 2016,
Microsoft released ASP dotnet core and this was
the first version. Now ASP dotnet core is built
on top of the new dotnet core framework dotnet
core is the very first platform version of dotnet.
And hence, it is not tied to just wait knows ASP
dotnet core as compared to the old version of MVC
is not tied to the dotnet framework assemblies
like system dot web. asp dotnet core team has
been very active with the new versions. And then
in 2017, they released dotnet core two followed
Buy 2.1 and 2.2 in 2018. Finally, in September
of 2019, ASP dotnet core three has been released,
which we will be using in this course. In this
video, let me show you all the tools that we'll
need for this course. The first and most important
is Visual Studio 2019. This is the ID that we'll
be using. You can go on Visual Studio dot
Microsoft comm forward slash Bs, and you can
download the community version for free, make sure
you download the 2019 if it is 2017 dotnet, core
3.1 will not work. Next, what you need is you have
to download the dotnet core 3.1 and install it. So
if you go on the Microsoft website for dotnet
core 3.1. Here, you can download the windows 4x
64 and install it. Once you install it, then when
you create a project in Visual Studio 2019, you
will see the dotnet core 3.1 option, which I will
discuss when we get there. But make sure both of
these are installed. After that, you will have to
install the SQL Server 2019 you can use an older
version of SQL Server but I would recommend the
latest one, you can download it for free for the
developer version. Once you install SQL Server, I
also want you to install the SQL Server Management
Studio, which will be a UI to your SQL Server. So
make sure you install all four of these features.
And that are all the tools that you will need. All
of these tools are free, so you should not have to
spend anything to install these software's on your
laptop or desktop. In this video, I want to show
you where you will find all the code that we'll
be building. For that one place will be you have
to go to brogan.com. in there, I have courses.
Right now we are on the free course, if you go
on the details, if you click course content,
it will download the completed code. But if
you want lecture by lecture on what was changed,
you can click on GitHub code. Here, it will open
up both the projects that we'll be building in
this course. here if you see the comments, they
will be based on the lecture name inside raiser as
well for each lecture, you will see what exactly
was changed or updated. And you can make sure that
you have those same things If you face any issue
in a particular lecture. So procon.com and in
there, you have to go to the courses to find out
what course you're on. And in there in details,
you will find the GitHub link. In this section,
we will be creating our very first project, it
will be a razor project. And then once we created
we will take a look at the files and folders that
are created. With this we will also understand how
an ASP dotnet core application is started. And
what are the files that are involved. So let's
get started with all of that from the next video.
When you open up Visual Studio 2019 it displays
a nice page on the left hand side you can see all
the projects you were working on. And on the right
hand side you can see options to create a new
project. So right here, we'll click on create
a new project. And once you do that, it will
display all of the templates that are available.
Out of this, we will select ASP dotnet core web
application. If you do not see on the top view
options, you can always search for that template
on the top. Once you find the ASP dotnet core web
application, let's hit the Next button. And we
need a project name. Let's call this book list
razor, and we'll change the location. I'll paste
the location where I want to create this project.
After that, we'll hit the Create button. And
we'll have more options for our project. In here,
the first thing to notice is we have dotnet
core and the dotnet framework. We will be
using the dotnet core and what version we want to
use, we want to use the latest version, which is
ASP dotnet core 3.1. Once you select that, then we
have few templates here. We can go with an empty
application and API project, a web application
which uses the razor pages or we can create an
application with MVC. Our main project will be
built using MVC, but the first project I want to
give you an introduction To razor pages, here, I
will display a CRUD operations so that you can get
comfortable with razor pages, because that will be
used inside the identity in our MVC application.
So we'll get a basic overview when we build this
project. Next, we have the authentication here,
you can select individual users account for
authentication. But right now, we do not want
to do that. Because if we do that some of the
things will already be configured for us. But I
want to start from scratch in this project. So
we'll just create a web application with razor
pages. Then before proceeding, we'll make sure
the source is dotnet core 3.1. And we'll hit
the Create button. Perfect. So with this, we have
created our project, and we'll be taking a look at
all the files and folders that we created from the
next video. In this video, we will take a brief
overview on what are razor pages, Razor pages have
been introduced in ASP. NET Core 2.0. And since
then, they have become the default way of coding
with ASP dotnet core stack. razor pages is a new
feature of ASP dotnet core that makes coding page
focused scenarios more easier and more productive.
They provide a simpler way to organize code
within ASP dotnet core applications. Keeping the
implementation logic and view models closer to the
view implementation code. razor pages is not just
for simple scenarios, everything that you can do
with MVC, you can do the same using razor pages,
like routing models, action result, tag helpers,
and so on. Finally, Razor pages have two parts.
First is the UI, which is more like the view in
MVC. And then we have the page model, which is
a combination of models, as well as view models
and the controller action methods. Let me switch
back to the application that we just created and
give you a quick demo of both the component. So we
are on the booklist razor. If we go to Solution
Explorer, inside pages, we will have the razor
pages. Let's take a look at the Index page. If you
see the Index page has an arrow, and there is dot
CSS, HTML, and dot CSS, HTML dot CSS, if you open
the dot CSS HTML, that is the result view all the
UI of razor pages and then the dot CSS, which is
not same as the code behind file, it is just a
naming convention. But this is actually the page
model for our index razor page. You can see it
extends from the page model class. Inside this
page model, we will define the model for this
view. Right here you can see it is index model.
And if you go on index, you can see the class
name is index model. In here, we have handlers,
which are like the controller action method. Right
now we only have the get handler that is defined
here. But we will be adding a post handler when we
want to post anything from our view or the razor
page. Another thing to notice is the name for the
get handler it is prefixed with the on keyword.
Similarly, if you had a post handler, it would be
something like this, in which we'll have public
wide on post, and we'll have the implementation
within the brackets. We will undo the change that
we did because I just wanted to show that right
now. But as we proceed, we will be implementing
the handlers for our razor pages. In this video,
let's take a look at the project configuration
file. In order to open that you can right click
on the project not on the solution but on the
project. And you have the Edit project file.
Or all you can do is double click on the project
name and it will open up the project file. The
file name would be the project name and then the
extension.cs project. project file has been there
since a long time but the format of the file and
how it works is different in ASP dotnet core three
in the initial versions of ASP dotnet core, we
had files called Project dot JSON and extra large.
The new cs proj file replaces both the file. Now
right here you can see within Property Group, we
have the target framework, which is NET Core app
three dot O, which is what we are using for this
project. The target framework here is also called
a node. After that we will be adding more packages
into our solution. Let me show you a quick way
we go to Tools nougat package manager solution.
And if we go on browse, let me install any first
package that we have. We have Newton soft JSON,
so we just installed that, don't worry, we'll come
back and uninstalled this. But I want to show you
for demo purposes, how the project file will be
affected. Perfect This is installed. If you go
to the project file again. Now you see a package
reference with Newton soft dot JSON. So every time
you add a nougat package, a package reference
entry would be added here. Right now we only
have one of them, which we just added. And if we
uninstalled this, it will go away. If we go back,
this should be gone. Whenever we need to add
more packages, we'll be adding more packages
as per our requirement. Now, if you have worked
with previous versions of ASP. NET Core, there
was a new good for meta package. And let me switch
to the presentation for that. And here we will be
discussing what was the meta package and what is
done with that the package has been discontinued.
And now it is a part of the dotnet core class
library. They are now updated automatically
when you update the version of dotnet core. Prior
to three dot o as I said before, the meta package
was included as a new get package. But now when
you install dotnet core on your Windows or laptop,
that meta package is installed automatically.
Also, some of the packages have been moved out
from that meta package like Entity Framework core,
which has been moved to its own nougat package,
which we will be installing in the future videos.
So that was a brief overview of where the meta
package is. Now with dotnet core three, you will
no longer see the meta package Microsoft dot ASP
NET Core dot app, it has been moved within
the dotnet framework. So it is installed
automatically when you install dotnet core. So
that gives you a brief overview of the Cs proj
file. Mainly it is to reference all of the nougat
packages and the target framework. In this video,
we will be taking a look at the properties
in our folder. If you expand the properties,
you will see a file called launch settings dot
JSON. This file tells ratio studio what to do when
you press the Run button right here on the top.
By default, we have few profiles here. By default,
we have few profiles here. The first one is the
IIS Express, which will launch IAS Express, which
will host the application and start a browser that
will hit the URL. It will also set the environment
variables to development. In this case, we can
detect the environment variables and make changes
based on that example, if it is development with
a load the full CSS and if it is production, then
we will load the minified version of CSS. There is
also a section to configure the IIS Express here,
you can set the launch variables here if you
scroll down further, we have another profile
called as population raiser, which is the project
name, it will run the application as a command
line application. So the internal castril which is
internal web server would be used, then a browser
would be started which hits the URL. These can
also be set by going into the properties of the
project, not the solution. And if we go on debug,
we have all the profiles right here. And you can
set the environment variables URL, SSL, and other
configuration. We will not be altering any of this
but I wanted to show you an overview of what it is
and where you can change that. Also inside the run
here, you will see all the profiles. So you can
select anyone to run your application. The next
thing that will be Taking a look is the www root
folder. If you expand this, you will see folders
for CSS JS level. This is a new thing that has
been introduced with ASP. NET Core. And this
has been created automatically. In this folder, we
will be placing all the static files like images,
CSS, JavaScript, and also static HTML. This folder
is the root folder for our website. None of the
code files that we'll be creating will go inside
this folder. So you shouldn't be placing any C
sharp or razor files here. This folder has been
created with an idea of having a nice separation
between code files, and the static files. Since
we created the application using MVC template,
we can see that Visual Studio has already placed
few bootstrap, CSS and other static files for us.
If you expand CSS, you see site dot CSS, with
GS, you have site or chairs. And inside the lib
folder, we have bootstrap, jQuery validations,
and some other scripts. Now the reason we have
all this CSS and JavaScript by default is we
created the web application as a razor page. If
we selected an empty application, we would have to
add all these files by ourselves. If you want to
explore that option, you can go ahead with that.
But with believing right is when we'll be adding
more CSS or JavaScript will always do that inside
our www root folder. So that is the one place for
all of your static files. In this video, we will
be taking a look at the pages folder inside our
razor project. So the main folder inside any razor
project is the pages folder. In here, we will have
all the pages that we want for our website, inside
the pages folder using a shared folder. And if you
expand this, we have underscored layout and
validation scripts partial. Now the name of
these two razor pages starts with an underscore,
which means they are partial views. Now partial
pages is something like user components, which
means you can reuse them in multiple places in
your website. The first one here underscore layout
is the default master page for your application.
So if you open this up right here, you see we have
the header for our application. You scroll down,
we have the main part, and we have the footer. We
also have the scripts that we want throughout our
application. And if you scroll up right here,
we have the CSS files. You can of course change
the default page that you have for the master
page. But we will keep it the same. And right
now it is underscored layout. Next, what we have
is validation scripts partial. Here we have just
included the JavaScript or jQuery that we will use
for validations. And in the pages where we want to
include that, we can just include this partial
page. After that outside of the shared folder,
we have the view import. Now with dotnet core
2.0. When above, we have tag helpers. And we will
understand in detail about tag helpers in just a
little while. But in the view import, you define
that you want to include tag helpers in your
application by adding this one line, which starts
with x tag helper. You can also add custom tag
helpers here if you create your own tag helpers,
and you want to register for this application.
You can also add your custom tag helpers that
you want to be used in your application. If for
some reason, you only want to use tag helpers for
some features, rather than defining this at global
level, you can also define it at individual page.
But I like to define it at the global level in
underscore view inputs so that when I need it,
it is already present. After that, we have the
underscore view start file. And here we define
which is the master page that we'll use for our
application. Right here you can see underscore
layout has been defined. After that what we have
the rest three are the actual razor pages. So
you can think about whatever we discussed so far
are more related to configuration master page and
user component. Then we have the Edit page, index
page and the privacy page. Now if you open up the
index dot CSS HTML right here you see the UI, or
the user interface with HTML and CSS. But where
is the page behind or the model defined here?
In MVC, we used to have controllers, but we do
not have that anymore in the razor pages. So if
you expand this, you see there is index dot CSS,
HTML dot CSS, and this is inheriting from page
model. And the name here is index model. If you go
to the Index page, you will see the model is the
same name. So whatever we define inside the page
model here will be used as the model for the index
razor page. This page model will be a code behind
for our index page. This is nowhere as close
to what we had in the classic ASP dotnet code
behind. This is completely rewritten and in a
completely different format. And we will call
this.cs file as the page model. And the.cs.
html will be the view or the razor page. Now
that we have a brief overview of where what code
goes, let's see routing in the next video when
we will see the index privacy and the application
coming along. One of the top level considerations
for the developer of a server side web application
framework is how to match URLs to the resources on
the server so that the correct one processes that
request. The most straightforward approach is that
you map URLs to the physical files on the desk.
And this is the approach that has been implemented
by the ASP. NET core team for razor pages
framework. Now there are some rules on how razor
pages framework matches URL to files, and how
rules can be customized to give different results
if needed. The first rule is that razor pages
needs a root folder. By default, the folder has
been named pages, and its location is inside the
root folder of the web application project. You
can configure another folder as the root folder
in the application configuration services method
inside the startup class, but that is beyond
the scope of this course. So we believe that
as the default page, if we have any requirements
that we had to change that, we would of course,
take a look at that. Let's switch back to the
application that we have. Right here you see the
root folder is the pages folder, and all of the
pages resides inside that. Of course, we can add
areas here and we can add pages inside the areas
folder, then that will become the root folder for
the application. Another rule is that the file
extension should not be included inside the URL
bat. So right here you see index dot CSS, HTML
inside the URL will only mentioned index. Then let
me switch back to the presentation. And the third
rule is that index dot CSS HTML is the default
file. Which means if a file name is missing from
the URL, the request will be mapped to index dot
CSS HTML inside that folder. Now let's take
a look at few examples. In the first example,
we have www.domain.com This will map to the pages
folder and then look for index dot CSS HTML page,
since we have not defined anything in the URL
index is the default page. In the second example,
we have www.domain.com forward slash index.
Again, in this it will look for the same index
page inside the pages folder, because we have
explicitly defined the Index page. Finally,
we have www.domain.com forward slash account.
Now here it has two ways to find the page. First,
it will try to find inside the pages folder.
First, it will try to find inside pages folder,
a file named as account dot CSS HTML, if it finds
that it will render that if it doesn't find that
then it takes that account could be a subfolder
name under pages. So it will check inside the
pages folder if there is a folder called account.
And inside that it will try to find index dot
CSS HTML. So we have few examples here for
routing. Let's see this in action. Let's go
to our project and run the application. In here,
you can see the URL is localhost, and we do not
have anything else. So that means by default, it
is loading the Index page. If we go back to our
application Solution Explorer, double click index,
you can see the text is welcome. And that is what
we are seeing right here. If we explicitly defined
index here, it will still load the same page. Now,
if we click on privacy, here, you can see it is
adding privacy. And if we go back to the solution,
privacy is inside pages, so you can directly
access that. Let me stop the application and
show you something else. I'll add a new folder.
And I'll call this with my name, again here,
and I've been moved privacy inside again.
Let's run our application and try to access
the privacy again. If we click here, it will not
load anything because privacy doesn't exist in the
same location. In order to access that you have to
type again, forward slash privacy. And with this,
it loads the privacy page correctly. So that
way, you can see that the linking of all the
pages is exactly what you see here. I'll move
the privacy back inside the pages folder,
and I'll delete my folder, not renamed. Perfect.
So this was a brief overview on how routing works.
And we'll be using more tag helpers and routing
as we proceed with the course. In this video,
we will take a look at tag helpers. Tag helpers
are brand new to ASP dotnet core, Microsoft looked
at the success around the other libraries like
Angular JS, react, and others, and decided that
implementing an Angular directive like experience
in the new ASP dotnet was so important to the
adoption of ASP dotnet core, and because of which
they decided to create tag helpers from ground up.
Tag helpers enable server side code to participate
in creating and rendering HTML elements inside
the reason files. Do there are similarities
between Angular directives and tag helpers,
there is a major difference. Tag helpers are for
server side rendering, while AngularJS directives
are all about client side rendering. Now you might
be wondering how tag helpers are compared to HTML
helpers. If you have worked with previous versions
of dotnet core HTML helpers are really just
methods throughout your razor markup. Tag helpers,
on the other hand, are very focused around HTML
elements and much more natural to use. Now let's
switch back to the application. And let's take a
look at few tag helpers that we already have. In
here, let's go on the Index page. And we do not
have any tag helpers associated inside here. But
if we go on underscore layout, there should be
plenty of tag helpers. Right here you can see the
tag helpers ASP area and ASP page. When we have to
redirect to any of the razor pages, we will use
the tag helper ASP page, and then we'll define
the path. Right here we want to go to the Index
page which is inside the pages folder. Hence,
we have defined forward slash index. Then if you
scroll down with more navigations, we again have
those tag helpers. If you scroll down further,
right here, we have another tag helper. And with
the script, we have the ASP up and version tag
helper. We will be using more tag helpers for
labels, forms and all of the buttons. But we'll do
that when we proceed. But the main thing about tag
helpers is you can use your regular HTML tag. And
you can just append a tag helper like you can with
other JavaScript frameworks. Also, I want to show
you few similarities that we have between the HTML
helpers and tag helpers. Both HTML helpers and tag
helpers performed the same functionality. But here
you can see that the label tag is so not HTML
friendly for HTML helper. But when you use tag
helper, you'll be using the same label tag class
attributes. All you have to do is add ASP for
tag helper. If you do not understand all of this
right now, do not worry as we proceed and start
coding This was start to make much more sense.
In classic ASP dotnet core in the system dot web
assembly took care of starting the application,
and global dot ASX had the methods in which you
could provide custom logic. The steps needed
to start up an application are now determined
by you. And that starts with the program class
file. The program class contains a main method,
which is the entry point for the application.
When the runtime executes the application,
it looks for this main method and calls it most
dotnet applications startup using the main method.
The application initially starts as a command
line application, the main method configures,
ASP, dotnet. Core, and start. So let's switch
back to the application and take a look at this.
So right here, we'll go to Solution Explorer, and
we have the program.cs. In here you see we have a
main method. Here, the configuration is done by
calling create host builder, which is a method
in the program class that returns I host builder
on that object build and run is called. And from
that point onwards, this application has become an
ASP dotnet core application. Create host builder
calls create default builder on a static web host
class, that configures the web host using default.
It deals with the configuration on how ASP. NET
Core deals with web server configuration files,
routing, and so on. You can see on top of the
default configuration, done by the Create default
builder to web builder is also configured to use
a startup class file. And if you go on the startup
class file by pressing F 12 here, or you can go to
Solution Explorer startup class file. Right here
you can see startup class is a simple class not
deriving from any other class. The runtime will by
convention, call two methods here. First is the
configured services. And we have the Configure
method. Let's take a look at both of them and the
startup class file in the next video. As we saw in
the previous clip, the runtime executes main which
among other things, configures, the startup class,
the runtime will call methods configure services
at Configure. Here we have an icon figuration
object that is being passed as dependency
injection to the startup class. Here with the
Configure services it is written, this method gets
called by runtime, it is used to add services to
the container. The purpose of configure services
method is to configure dependency injection,
dependency injection in classic ASP dotnet
was optional. In ASP. NET Core, it forms an
integral part of the ASP. NET itself. This method
add services to the application to make them
available, you get the service collection object
that is injected into the matter as parameter. Now
you can use this to build on the services that
will be available to this application. Examples
of the services would be Entity Framework, core
Identity Service, MVC, and many more. By default,
you will have the Add razor pages available,
you will not have the razor compilation here.
So do not worry, it should look like this, you
will only have the Add razor pages. And this is
because when we created the project, we selected
that we want the razor pages. The other method
is the Configure method. And here this method
is used to configure the HTTP request pipeline.
The pipeline specifies how the application should
respond to HTTP requests. pipeline is composed of
individual parts called middleware. Let me switch
to a presentation to explain that better. Now, in
any general scenario, what we will have is we will
have a browser and then we will have a pipeline in
which we will make a request and we will get back
a response. The individual parts that make up a
pipeline are called middlewares. Let's consider
a few of the middlewares that we can add in a
pipeline. One of them can be MVC, and then we You
can also add authentication and static files. You
should notice that when we add authentication
middleware, it should be done before we add MVC.
And the order is important. The reason is we do
not want to load MVC and then find out that user
is not authenticated. We also have to configure
a middleware for static files in our project,
like HTML files, images, CSS, or JavaScript files.
Now when the data travels through the pipeline,
it gets manipulated by individual middlewares. And
so does the response or the result. Let's take a
look at a 10,000 foot image of what happens
when this request is made in the next video.
So when the request is made from the browser, it
first arrives at a web server like a yes is will
then invoke the dotnet runtime, which would load
the CLR and then look for an entry point in your
application. It will find that in the main method
of the program class and execute it, which starts
the internal web server in your application,
we will have cash rule in our application,
the main method and the startup class would
configure the application and the request would be
routed from is to cash flow, and then it will be
pushed to the application. After that it will be
processed by all the middlewares and the generated
response will be routed back to the cached role,
which will route it back to the is that will
finally produce the response on the browser.
This is much more efficient than the old
system dark web approach. Classic system
relied heavily on system dot web, which was
tied to IIS. But using a pipeline approach,
we only plug in the middlewares that we need.
Everything we plug in is in a separate assembly
exposed in a new get. Now since system ductwork
was tied to is and is is tied to Windows, that
is the reason you cannot run classic ASP dotnet
on other web servers, then IIS and Windows. Now
since that is no longer the case, ASP dotnet core
applications can be run on web servers and other
operating systems. One thing you should keep in
mind is that there are two web servers. One is
external like IAS or Apache or Linux. And that
is also an internal web server hosted by your
application request from the external web server
are passed to the internal web server and other
way around. You can choose different internal web
server, but most common is cashkaro. Since it has
first class support in ASP dotnet core. Cash Flow
is a lightweight web server which can only execute
a request. Because of age, you need external web
server to configure other options like security,
hashing, and so on. This was a brief overview on
how middleware and pipeline comes to the picture.
Let me switch back to the application that we were
looking at an inside the Configure method. You can
see we have plugged in multiple middlewares
using App and then the middleware name,
we check if it is development, we want to
use the developer exception page or else we
want to use just a generic error page. Then
we have the HTTPS redirection middleware,
we have the middleware for static files. Because
of the static files middleware, we will be able
to use the CSS JavaScript and images that we will
add inside the WW root folder. Then we have the
app dot use routing. And then we have app dot use
authorization. Finally, we have used endpoints
with dotnet. Core three, they have introduced
endpoint routing, in which you can configure
multiple routes. We will understand why we need
this and we can configure more than one endpoints
here for different technologies, which we will see
in upcoming videos. But right now the main thing
to consider is you can see how we are plugging
in different middlewares. Now we have used the
terminology middleware quite a few times. So let's
actually understand what middlewares are. Now that
we have seen the overview of how Application
flow. Let's understand middlewares and pipeline
in much more detail. Whenever an HTTP request
comes in, something must handle that request.
So it eventually results in an HTTP response.
Those pieces of code that handles the request
and results in a response make up the request
pipeline, what we can do is configure this request
pipeline by adding middlewares, which are software
components that are assembled into an application
pipeline to handle request and response. So
typically, a browser is going to send a request
to your server. And that request is going to
be interpreted by the server, and handled by
some piece of software. Now first, that request is
attached to something called as the context object
as a part of software that manages this context.
In our case, it would be ASP. NET Core middleware,
you can essentially Think of it as a pipeline,
which is a series of pipes, that is going to
determine what is going to happen to the context.
So first, the request is passed along the first
pipe, and the first pipe interprets the context
and checks out the request and determines if there
is some type of response needed and attach that
to the context. If there is no immediate response
that should be handed back to the server, then the
context is simply passed along to the next pipe in
the pipeline. This continues, again to the next
piece of middleware, whatever it might be, and it
goes on till it reaches the very last pipe. Now,
it is also possible that at end of the pipeline,
no response has been found. And that will cause
a 404, not found and written back to whoever
originated the request. However, it is possible
that in any one or more of these middlewares,
there may be a response that needs to be passed
back. And it could happen in any of the pipes.
So sometimes it could happen that middleware
would not pass the context along the next piece,
but rather says, Okay, I have a response
that I need to send back. But typically,
your context will go all the way through
the pipeline to the end, by the last piece
of middleware sends a response, which gets back
through the pipeline to the server, and then the
server sends back the response to the browser.
This is a very simplified version of how request
works. Let me just walk you through that, again,
in a brief overview so that this makes complete
sense. When the request comes in to the server.
The server then accesses the dotnet core framework
and puts the request into a context object, the
context gets passed along to the middlewares. And
if a middleware has a response anywhere along
the way, then it will attach that response to
the context object, and then pass that context
object back through the pipeline to the server,
and then the server sends back the response to the
browser. Now keep in mind, the order of pipeline
is important. It always gets past from the first
to the last. A good example will be authentication
middleware. If the middleware component finds the
request is an authorized, it will not pass it to
the next piece of the middleware, but it will
immediately return an unauthorized response. It
is hence important that authentication middleware
is added before other components that shouldn't
be triggered. In case of an unauthorized request.
We will be adding more middlewares in our project,
but we'll do them as we face the requirement for
that. Another file that we have in our project is
app settings dot JSON. All of the application
settings are contained in this file. And any
changes to the app settings dot JSON file will
require restarting of the IIS administration to
take effect. Let's switch back to the application
and take a look at this file. So if we go here,
we have the app settings dot JSON file. In
here right now you see we only have logging
we have log level and few other details. We will
be adding more settings here for connection string
and also if you add new other data details like
maybe something related to dependency if there
are some security keys or anything, you can also
add them here. You can also store them remotely
on a server. But app settings is generally a
place where you have them when you're initially
developing. In the future videos, we will be
adding more settings here like connection strings,
and we'll be accessing this variables inside
the startup class file when we use dependency
injection. So that's the brief overview of the
app settings dot JSON file. ASP. NET Core supports
dependency injection software design pattern,
which is a technique for achieving inversion of
control between classes and their dependencies.
Now, you might be wondering what is IOC or
inversion of control container. IOC container is
a framework for implementing automatic dependency
injection. It manages object creation and
its lifetime and also injects dependencies
to their class. IOC container creates an object
of the specified class and also inject all of the
dependency objects through constructor property or
method at runtime, and disposes it at appropriate
time. This is done so that we do not have to
create and manage the objects manually. Support
for dependency injection is built into ASP dotnet
core. In ASP dotnet core, both framework services
and application services can be injected into
your classes, rather than being tightly coupled.
dependency injection is a design pattern in
which a class or object has its dependent classes
injected, rather than creating them directly.
dependency injection can help developers decouple
the different pieces of their application. Let's
try to see this with an example. We have Bob here
who has been thinking about going on hiking. So
he makes a list of all the supplies like maps,
flashlights, protein bars, etc, and puts them in
a backpack. Now next day, when he goes on hiking,
he takes the backpack with him. This pack acts
as a container. So during the hike, whenever he
needs anything, he takes it out of the container
and uses them. This is the simple concept that
you put items you will need in a container. And
when you need them, it already exists inside a
container. Let's understand this in a way that
is more related to coding. Let's imagine our
application have three pages. And in each page, we
will need three functionalities, we need to lock
something we need to send email, and we need to
save something to our database. So we will need
to create objects of these functions. In classic
days, we'll be creating objects of email, database
and logger in the first page, then we will do the
same in the second page, and so on. But this is
different with dependency injection. Let's take
a look at that. With dependency injection. Again,
we have the same three pages, and we want the
same three functionalities or the classes,
we have a dependency injection container, what we
will do is we will register all the three classes
inside our container. Whenever any page will need
anything, we will directly extracted from that
container. Rather than creating the new object in
individual pages. It is created and registered in
the container, we only have to use this. This way
container deals with creating, registering and
disposing of the objects rather than creating them
in every page. This is how efficient dependency
injection is compared to the classic approach. Now
that our project is created in this section, we
will start building all the functionalities in our
project, we will first add the model that we want
to and push it to database. After that we will
perform CRUD operations on book list. With that we
will complete our project with the razor pages and
you will see how everything comes to picture. So
let's get started with all of that from the next
video. In this video, we will be installing Our
first nougat package. So for that, let me run the
application and show you why we need that package.
So when you hit the Run button, it will load
our website. And you can see the default layout
that we have. We have a homepage and a privacy
page. Let's go to our home razor page and edit
this text. So for that, we'll switch back to our
application. And we'll go to Solution Explorer,
all of the pages will be inside the pages folder.
When we double click on index dot CSS, HTML, and
right here, while the application is running, with
an add my name, plug in here, save it, go back and
refresh. You can see the refresh was successful,
but the content here did not change. This was an
existing feature before ASP dotnet core three.
But with three, they have decided to add this
auto refresh for the view as a separate package.
So we'll stop the application, we'll go to Tools,
nougat package manager, and manage nougat
packages for solution. Inside the Browse tab,
we will search for Microsoft dot ASP NET Core dot
MVC dot razor dot runtime compiled nation, we have
to install this package inside our booklists to
raise our project will accept this. And once the
installation is complete, we need to make one
change inside our startup.cs class file. And
we have the Configure services method. In here,
while we have the dot add razor pages, we will
have dot add razor runtime compiler nation. After
you add this line, if you press f5 or hit the Run
button here, it will load the website again. And
the content will be welcome again right now. Let's
see that perfect. Let's switch back. Let's go back
to our index and remove again. And let's refresh
the page. And this time, it should automatically
reload and it should display welcome. Great,
you can see that in action. And with this whenever
you will change anything inside the razor UI.
And you come back here while the application is
running, and refresh, this should automatically
refresh. This is one of a core package that is
needed for developers. Because we are many times
dealing with the view, we make changes, we come
back and we want to see the change rather than
restarting the application. In this video, what we
will do is we will be adding our first model. Now
models represents any table that you want in your
database. In this project, what we want to do is
we want to manage a list of books so far that we
will add a model or a table called book. In order
to do that, in our project, we'll write like add,
let's add a new folder to separate things out. And
we'll call this model. Inside here. We'll right
click, add a new class file. And we'll call this
book. Then in here, we will add few properties.
First, we'll be the ID. So we'll say prop. This
will be an integer ID, this will be a unique key.
So we can add a data annotation by typing key. And
if we do control dot here, you'll see using system
dot component model data annotation, what key will
do is it will automatically add ID as an identity
column. So that way we do not have to pass the
value, it will create an ID value automatically.
Along with ID we also want name of the book. So we
do prop screen and name. Then we want the author.
So we'll do prop again, prompt is a snippet for
property. So if you type prop and hit Tab twice,
it will automatically create a property. We'll
call this as author. And let's make a string. Now
for name I want to display book name. so far that
we have a display attribute and we also have a
required data annotation. Let's try the required
first when we do required This means that name
cannot be no the display data annotation I will
add it as we proceed with the course. So this
looks good for my book and these three properties
should be sufficient Once we have created this
book, next thing is to add this to database. For
that, we have to add few packages for Entity
Framework. And we have to set up connection
string. Let's do that in the next video. Now that
we have added a book model inside our project,
we need to set up the database. In order to set
up the database, we need few packages. So we'll
go to Tools, nougat package manager, and package
manager solution. Here, the first package we want
is Microsoft dot Entity Framework core, we'll
select this, the version is three dot o looks
good, that's installed this. These are all the
Entity Framework packages that we are needing,
because we'll be using Entity Framework to Access
database. After this, we need that SQL Server.
So we'll search for that. And we'll be using SQL
Server. So we'll add this package as well. And the
final package that we'll need is Entity Framework
core dot tools. And this is required because we'll
be running migrations, I will explain you in
the next video what exactly migrations are,
so don't worry, but these are the three packages
that you need. If you remove and close this,
your application should have this four
packages right now. Okay, so with this,
we have installed all the necessary packages.
Now we need to set up our connection string.
Let's go to SQL Server real quick. And in here,
when you try to connect, you need a server name,
the server name that you see right here, local DB
in bracket backward slash MS SQL local dB. This
is the default server name that SQL server has.
So right here, we'll use this in our connection
string. So let me just go back. And the connection
string that we'll be adding will be inside app
settings dot JSON, as I explained before, so
for connection string right here before logging,
let me just paste that. This is what you need
to write. It will be connection strings with a
plural s at the end. And we'll set up a default
connection, you can give default connection, any
other name that you want. Then for the CRN world,
we have the exact server name that we see inside
SQL Server, make sure this is aligned. And also
try to connect. Once you connect. This means that
this server name is valid. After that, you can use
the same server name here. Then for the database,
we'll create a new database called vocalist
raiser, make sure that you do not create that
database automatically from SQL Server, we will be
doing that using Visual Studio. So right now you
see we do not have published razor database here.
We'll go back we have the trusted connection true,
and we have the multiple active results adds to
true, I will be pasting this exact string with
the lecture as well, so that you don't have to
waste time to type this manually. But make sure
the server name is valid with what you have.
Once the connection string is in app settings
dot JSON. Next thing we have to do is we have
to configure our startup class file. And let's
do the configuration and brand migrations in
the next video. Now that we have the connection
string inside app settings dot JSON, it's time
to configure our configured services with Entity
Framework. In order to configure that we need an
application DB context or a DB context class. So
that class we can add inside Solution Explorer
model, right click Add a new class. We'll call
this class application DB context. Let's add this.
Now the application DB context should inherit
from DB context class, which is a class inside
Microsoft dot Entity Framework core. After this,
we need to implement the constructor. And we
have to pass the DB context options to the
parent class. So for constructor we have a snippet
called CTR, and we'll press Tab twice. Right here,
we have to pass the DB context options. And in
here, we need the application DB context. We'll
call this options. This will have to pass to the
base and we'll pass the options here. This is an
empty constructor but the parameter is needed
for dependency injection. Once we have that,
then we need to Add the book model that we added
to our database. In order to add any model to the
database inside the DB context, you need an entry,
we will do public and this will be DB set of type
book. And let's call this property to blog as
well. Once you add this, the last thing that
you have to do is add the DB context inside
startup.cs. So inside startup.cs, we have to
add the DB context to our pipeline. So we'll say
services dot add DB context. And right here, we
have to pass our class name, which is application
DB context, we'll do our control dot here. And
we need to pass the options with connection
string. So we'll say options dot use SQL Server,
we'll have to do a control dot here. And the use
SQL Server we added as a nougat package. In here,
we need to pass the connection string from
our app settings dot JSON. So for that,
we can use the configuration object that we have.
So we'll just say configuration.in. Here, we have
to get connection string. And we need to pass
the name that we used for our connection string,
which is default connection. We'll copy this, and
we'll pass this in a string notation like this.
So this was the configuration that we had to do to
include Entity Framework inside the configuration
pipeline. Once you have this, all you have to do
is you need to push this to database. So for that,
we'll go to Tools new get package manager, this
time, we'll be going to package manager console.
And in here, the project name, it should be
published razor, we'll type the command add
migration, and we will add a meaningful name. What
we are doing right now is add book to database or
DB will press Enter. And what add migration
will do is it will create a script that will
be executed across the database. The script has
been created right here you see what the script
is doing is it is automatically creating a table
called book. And it is adding the columns ID name
and author. It is also making sure ID nullable
is false. And name nullable is false. Author
nullable is true, because if we go, we do not
have any required attribute with otter. Since
it is a key it knows that it is not nullable
in the constraint, it is also adding primary
key for the table. And in the annotation. It is
making sure that ID is identity column. So this
is the perfect script that is needed to create
the book table. Now right now only script has
been created with the Add migration command. How
do we actually create the database and create
the table. For that we have a command called
update database. Once you hit update database,
it will check if the database exists. If it does
not, it will create the database. And it will
also push the migrations. Once the update database
command completes successfully, you can go back to
your SQL Server and to the database. Let's refresh
it. Right now if you expand this and go on tables,
you see we have the book table that has
been created. And if you do select up 1000,
you will see the three columns. Perfect. So with
this, we created our database. And we also added
the book table with the properties that we wanted.
Now the purpose of this course is to perform CRUD
operations on this book object. So for that we
need pages to create a new book, edit a new book,
delete a book, and also view all of the books that
are available. So we'll go to Solution Explorer.
And inside pages, we have the Index page and
few other pages. All of the book pages. Let me
add this in a new folder. And we'll call this
book vest. In here let me add a new razor page.
So what you have to do is right click Add and
will add a razor page. We will go with the empty
razor page because going with this will solve our
problems, but we will not know what was done. So
we'll go with the empty razor page. And let's call
this index. What are all the options here? First
option is to create a page model class. As you
saw with the Index page, here, we have index page
as well as page model, we need a page model class
because we need to populate all of the books from
the database and pass that to the page to display
it. So that's why we'll need that, then this won't
be a partial view, a partial view is something
which is a small subsection, like maybe group of
buttons that you want to reuse in multiple places
in your website. But this is a complete page. So
that won't be a partial view. And we will use our
layout page because that is the master page. And
we want to be consistent. So with this, let's add
this. One drawback that I see with the razor pages
is when we will be adding index pages, it might
get confusing, because you see we have a master
index page. Inside vocalist, we have another
index page. So whenever you are working, make
sure you are working on the correct index page.
At this time, we'll be working on index an index
page model inside the book list. So if you have
any other pages open, you can close them. Inside
the Index page, what we want to do is we want to
retrieve all of the books from the database. So
for that, we need the application DB context.
Whenever you have to deal with the database,
you will need the application DB context. When you
added the application DB context right here in the
services, that means that you have added it to the
pipeline. Once you have added it as a pipeline,
you can use them using dependency injection. So we
need an object of application DB context, what you
will do is use a private read only application DB
context. And let's call this underscore dB. Now we
need to initiate our constructor. So we'll type
CT or our tab tab. And right here, we will get
the application DB context dB. This application DB
context we are getting using dependency injection.
So right here, we'll say underscore DB is equal
to dB. This way, you can extract the application
DB context that is inside the dependency injection
container and injected onto this page. If you did
not have dependency injection, what you would have
to do is you would have to create a new object.
And then once you are done with that, you'll have
to dispose that and all the other things. With
dependency injection, you do not have to worry
about anything. Now what we want to do is we
want to return a list or an ienumerable of book.
So we'll say public I enumerable. of book. Let's
call this books, we'll have the getter and setter,
what we will do is we'll assign this books,
all of the books from the database. How do we
get that it's way too simple. Because we're using
Entity Framework. We'll use a weight here. And
we'll say underscore DB dot books, you can see it
already has the book. And we have a method here,
which is to list and we'll call the async method,
we'll have to do a Ctrl Dart for the async to
use Entity Framework core. Now when you are using
async and await rather than why you will have to
use async task. What we are doing here is we are
going to database and retrieving all of the books
storing that inside the I enumerable. And we are
doing that inside the get handler. So when we
go inside the view here, we will already have
the list of books available to display. All you
did was right here, you extracted that and it is
already available inside your view to display.
Now one thing to notice is right now I'm using
await and async. What async does, this is a basic
C sharp explanation and not related to dotnet
core. So I won't be going into much details. But
async will basically let you run multiple tasks
at a time until it is awaited. Right here we need
to await because we need to assign all the books
that we found. But the method that we have is also
a sink and task. So this was all you had to do for
the get handler. Again, if it was MVC this would
be action methods, but with razor pages inside
the page model. We have handlers in the next week.
Do let's write some code here and see the list of
books. Now that we have added the get handler
method for the Index page inside book list,
it's time to add some UI. Here, the first thing
we'll do is we'll go to Solution Explorer. And
we'll go to our master page, which is underscored
layout. We have home and privacy, that may add a
book tab in place of privacy. And for that,
we have to change the ASB page. So for that,
rather than privacy, we will have foreclosed
forward slash index. And if you save this,
let's run our application. Once you click on this,
it should load the Index page. In order to see the
difference, you have to go here and let me type
index book save this. And let's click on the
book. Perfect, you can see the page is loaded. So
with this, you can see inside underscore layout,
how you had to manipulate the routing for the ASP
page tag helpers. If you want to access something
inside the book list, you have to write the book
list name, followed by the page that we have,
which is the Index page, then we can keep
this application running, we can go to index,
and we'll design this. So we'll just remove this,
let me add br, then let me just remove this index,
and we'll start designing this page. We also
do not need the view data, we can remove that,
we'll add a br and we'll add a div give it a class
of container. These are the bootstrap classes row,
padding zero and margin zero. Within this first
container, I'll add a div give it a class of
column 10. And I'll also add another div give it a
class of column two. If you are not familiar with
bootstrap, bootstrap divides a row into 12 equal
columns. So that's why I'm dividing one column
inside two separate columns. First will occupy
10 columns, and the next one will be the rest
two columns. Inside here, I'll use edge to give
it a bootstrap class of text info for a bluish
color. And we're display Polk vest. In here, we
will add an anchor tag. And we'll give it a class
of btn btn. info, and form control. These are all
bootstrap classes. And let's say create new book.
Let's save this. Let's go back and refresh the
page. Perfect. This is coming along good. Let me
increase the size here. So we can do column three.
And we'll have to make it column nine. Perfect,
this is good. We'll just make it text white
here. So right here, we can do text white. Okay,
this looks good. Now what we want to do is we want
to display a table with all of the books. Let's
continue working on the designing in the next
video. Let's continue working on the designing
right now we have the Create new book. But when
we click nothing happens, and that is because we
have not used any tag helpers on where it should
redirect. We'll do that in while after this column
nine and column three. Let me add another div
give it a class of column 12. We'll give it a
border padding three and margin top of three or
bootstrap classes. And we'll add a form here,
give it a method of post. Within this form, we
want to display this only if books exist inside
the table. So we can use razor syntax here like
if else condition. For that you need add sign.
And then you can use C sharp syntax like if and
we want to check if there are any books that are
returned from this get method. You can see inside
the page model we have the ienumerable as book.
So inside the razor page, you can say model with
a capital M dot. Right here you can see books is
available. This is the same box that is being
passed from the get handler right here. So we
can check if model dot books dot count. If this is
greater than zero, then we will display a table.
Else we will display a paragraph and say no books
available. Let's save this. Let's go back and
refresh and we should see no books available.
Now in order to see some books right now we
do not have the Create book page. So let's go to
database and hack some things. We'll right click
on the book at the top 100. Let me do one, one,
and any of the dummy record, we'll come back here,
and we'll refresh and that message is gone. And
that is because it retrieved one book that we just
added. So how do we display that? Right here, we
will have to add a table inside the if condition.
So we'll add table give it bootstrap classes of
table, table striped, and water. Within here,
we'll add a tr give it a class of table secondary.
And we will add a th for the table heading. Here,
we will use the label tag helper and the tag
helper we have is ASP for we will go to our
books. And in here, we want the first or default,
because the label we want for only one record. And
we'll say dot name. So this is how you can use tag
helper. You can also use HTML helper for the same
thing. Let me show you that for the author. So the
syntax for HTML helper was pretty weird. So it was
HTML dot display name for and in here, you will
have to use the lambda expression m goes to m dot
books dot first dot default dot author. Now you
can see how tag helpers have made this extremely
simple. It is the existing label tag, all you did
was add a SP four. So that's why tag helpers are
preferred over HTML helpers. But HTML helpers are
still there for some functionalities, which you
have to write custom tag helpers for. And I will
show you that in just a while. Once you have this,
let me add a th here. And I will comment this code
out. But I will leave there for reference. I will
copy this and paste it here for author. So this
was the table header, we will add an empty th tag.
After this we want all of the records. So for that
we need a for each loop. How do we get a for each
loop inside the view? Again, the answer is add
sign. And then we have the for each which is a
C sharp syntax, we'll say variable item in model
with a capital M dot books. So for all of the
books that we have, we will have item and we will
display a table row here. So we will add a tr tag
and inside the TD we want to display the value.
Now in this case, we do not have a tag helper,
but we have an HTML helper. The HTML helper
is HTML dot display for in here, we'll have
to use link m goes to item.we want to display the
name, we do not have an equivalent tag helper for
display for of course, you can write a custom
tag helper that can do the exact same thing.
But that is beyond the scope for this project. So
we can just use the HTML helper. We can copy this
and we'll paste it again for author. Let me save
this. Let's go back and refresh. And we should see
our record. Perfect. This was so easy. Now this
is not aligned. So we can do Ctrl A Ctrl KD to
align everything that we have. Last thing that I
want is in here, I want buttons to edit or delete
a book. So after this TD, and we'll add another
TD and ever give button, give it a class. Give it
a class of btn btn danger, and btn small these
are all bootstrap classes. And I will display
delete. After the delete button, we need a link
to redirect to the Edit page. So for that, we'll
use the anchor tag. And we'll give it a class
of btn btn success 10 we'll do btn small here,
this will be added. Let me save this and refresh.
And great this is good. We will not worry about
designing much things here. But this looks good.
In delete. I'll just do text white so that it
is aligned with the Delete. So with this we have
almost completed the Index page but we will come
back here later. Now The last thing that I want to
do on index page for this video is on create book,
I want to add a link so that it redirects me to a
create razor page. So for that right here, inside
the Create new book, you will need a tag helper,
the tag helper we have seen before in underscore
layout, it is ASP page, what page do we want to
redirect to that will be a Create Page. Now you do
not have to mention here that the Create Page will
be inside book list. Because if you are in the
same folder, you can directly write the page name.
That being said, let's add the Create Page in the
next video. In this video, we will be adding the
Create razor page. So let me stop the application,
we'll go to Solution Explorer, inside the
booklet will write like add a razor page. Again,
it will be the basic one. And we'll say create
here, it won't be a partial view. Let's add this.
Now with the Create Page when the page will
be loaded to we want to display any data. No,
we just want to display textbox. So user can enter
a book name and an author. So for that right here,
we will again need the application DB context, not
for the get handler. But when we hit the Create
button, we need to save it to our database. So we
will just do that while we are here. So we'll say
private read only application DB context, we'll do
a ctrl.to add model. And we'll have underscore dB.
We need constructor. So CTR tab tab will get the
application DB context dB, then underscore DB is
equal to dB. Now inside the get method, we need
to display text boxes to write the author name
and the book name, what will be the model. So that
will be public book, let me call that book, we'll
have the getter and setter. On get we do not have
to write that we will be passing this empty book
object, it does that automatically. So inside the
Create view, you will be able to access this book
and display labels as well as text boxes. Before
we do that in the next video. Many times it's
a common situation that you start with a model
and then you feel no I need one more property,
or they are like Whoops, I need to rename this.
So for that what we will do is right here, let's
imagine we have to add a new property called isbm.
So we'll write the new property is b n. And let's
have a getter and setter. Once you add a property
since you change something in the model here, you
have to add a new migration. So we'll go to Tools
nougat package manager, package manager console
will right add migration, add ESPN to book model,
always try to name your migration as meaningful as
possible. For effect, you can see it is adding a
new column. And all you do is update database. So
this way inside your table, a new column will be
added. If you go back now, and if you do select
top 1000 you can see I ESPN has been added, which
is no this looks great. And now we know how we can
make changes to a model that we have already
added. We'll have to change our index for the
same. I'll just copy this and paste it one more
time or turn off the display for here we'll have
the iasb n. And we'll do the same for HTML helper.
Perfect. So these are all the changes that were
needed. In the next video. Let's design the Create
Page and see everything in action. In this video,
we will start designing the Create razor page. We
will remove all of these things. We'll add a br
we'll give it a heading here, give it a class
of text info. And let me display create a new
book followed by a br. Now let me just paste some
bootstrap styling that we have I aligned this. All
I did was I added a div give it a class of border
and container and some style with padding. Then I
added a form and in that form I have a div with
class of form group and row Inside that row, I
have divided this into two parts, column two, and
column six. Let me make it column four, and column
six. That should be okay. Even though the total
should add up to 12, you can leave it like this.
Once you have the same designing, what we will do
is within the form, we will add method of post,
because when we hit the Create button, we will be
posting data back to our page handler. Within the
column for we want to display label. So we'll do
label and ESB for this will be for book.we have
the name. After that we have column six here, we
want a text box. So we'll say input, we'll use the
tag helper ESP for this is for book dot name. And
we'll give it a class of form control. You can see
how easy the binding is with the tag helpers, you
do not need to worry about anything in the post
book dot name will have the value that user enters
inside this text box. So let me just copy this and
paste this two more times. We have author and we
have ESPN. After author and ISP een we will add
another div give it a class of form group and row
just like we did before. And we'll add a div give
it a class of column three offset of two. Let me
do column six offset of four. That's what we have.
And we'll add a div give it a class of column
four, this should be column three, and this will
be column three. This is because the six that we
have, we are dividing that into two columns again,
the first one will be an input. And this will be
type of submit for the button. And we'll give it
a value of create. Give it some bootstrap classes
of btn btn, primary and form control. The other
one is to go back to the Index page. So we'll use
the anchor tag and the tag helper ESB page will
take us back to the Index page. And the classes
will be btn btn, success and form control will
display back to list. Let me save this and run
our project. We'll go to our book. And this time
we'll hit Create new book. Great, you can see how
good the page is coming along. If you think the
size is too big here, you can always modify that
I'll change this to three in all the places. And
that way it will be more closer. Offset will also
be three. Let's save this. And perfect looks much
better. Now if you click on back to worst, it
works and uncreate we need to work on what will
happen when we hit the submit button. Right now if
you do that nothing happens. And that is because
inside the Create Page model, we do not have a
post handler. So let's see how we can add a post
handler so that whenever they submit anything
from the page, how do we get the data and save
that inside our database. In this video, we need
to make sure when we fill all of this information
and hit the Create button, it takes us back to the
page. But before that we need some validation. As
you know name was a required property. So
if you hit Create before pressing the name,
we want to see the error message right here. We'll
do all of that. Let's stop the application. And
let's go to the page model. Right here we have the
on get handler. But when we hit the submit button,
we will be posting data. So for that we need a
post handler to retrieve that. So we'll create
public async and task. This task will be of eye
action result because we'll be redirecting to a
new page. And the handler name will always start
with on and what is the handler name. We want
a post handler so it will be on post. When this
will be posted what will be passed from this razor
page. We will be passing a book object so far that
will retrieve a book object. And we'll call this
book OBJ. Now, rather than getting a book object
like this, we already have a book right here,
we can use the exact same property rather
than writing this ESP dotnet core team has
given a property binding here, where you have to
write bind property. Once you bind the property,
it is automatically assumed that on the post, you
will be getting this book right here. So that way,
all you have to do is right here, you can check
if model state.is valid, then proceed further.
Else. If it is invalid, we want to return back to
the page. I'll explain you what model state is.
But hang with me right now. If the model state is
valid, we want to add the book to database. Adding
that is really simple. We can use the underscore
DB in here we have the book. And we have an add
a sink right here. What is the parameter we want
to add the book with just do a wait here, and this
will work. After we add the book, we need to save
changes to the database. Right now, this book has
not been added to the database, it is just added
to a queue, which will be eventually pushed to the
database. When we type the command underscore DB
dot Save Changes a synchronously, only when this
command is executed, then the data will be pushed
to the database. And once the changes are pushed
to the database, all that is remaining is return,
we will redirect to a page. And that page will be
the Index page. This looks good. Let's run our
application and see this in action. So we'll go
to book, we'll try to create a new book. And let's
hit the Create button. Great, you can see the book
has been created. Now let's try to create a new
book and hit the Create button. You'll see nothing
happens. If you type name here and hit create,
it gets created. But if you try it without name,
it won't be created. And that is because name is
a required property. what is actually happening is
if we add a debugger here, and if we go back and
try to hit the Create button, the control goes
back here. And let me add few more debuggers hit
continue the model state if you hover is invalid,
what is not valid if you go on model state, you
will have to go to result view. And right here you
will see the name is invalid. And the reason it
is invalid is it is a required property. And you
are not passing any value. But we need some error
messages to see that it is actually an error. In
order to do that, let me hit Continue. And we go
back inside the view here, we need to add a div
will additive give it a class of text danger,
this will be a red color. And that is a special
tag helper ASP Validation Summary, we'll change
this to model only. Once we have this, what we
need is we want to display individual error. So
we'll add span here. And we have ASP validation
for tag helper. Here we want the validation for
book dot name will give it a class of text danger.
We can copy this will do the same for author,
and ESPN. Once you do this, if you save this,
go back and refresh the page. The control comes
back here. Let's hit the continue. Whoops,
I think there are some changes. We'll just stop
this. Remove the debugger now. And let's just run
the application again. This time if we go to book
and if we try to create new book hit the Create
button. You can see the error message comes right
up. I need to show one more thing here. Let me
show you that in the next video. Now we see the
error message. But there is one more issue. If
you go back to the application while it's running.
Let's add a debugger here in the model state and
hit the Create button again. You can see that
the control is going to the on post handler,
it finds the model status invalid, and it
returns back with the error. We want this to
be done on the client side. In order to do that,
if we switch back, we go to create, right here,
inside Solution Explorer, we have the validation
scripts partial, all we have to do is we need
their reference. So right here, we'll do add
section, this will be scripts. And right here,
we will use partial tag helper name, we will
paste the name, this name will be exactly same as
validation scripts partial, make sure there is no
spelling mistake, we'll save this. Let's go back,
go back to the homepage. Let me do Ctrl f5, for
hard refresh. Let's try to create again. And let's
make it empty, hit the Create button, you see the
error message pops up, it doesn't go back. And to
confirm if we go back, we still have our debugger.
So this means the validation here is done on the
client side without posting back. So that way, we
have both the validation server side as well as
client side. So this was one way I wanted to show
you that the validation should be done both client
side as well as server side. Now the Create is
completed in the next video, let's start working
on the Edit functionality. Now we will be working
on the Edit razor page. So while this is running,
if we can go back, and we go to our index. If
we scroll down where we have the edit in here,
we need to pass the routing. So the ASB page, this
will be the Edit page, which we will create. Now
whenever an user clicks on the Edit button,
we want to pass the ID of the field that they
are editing. In this case it will be ID of the
book. So in order to pass that we have another
tag helper, and that is ASP, we have route. And
then we need to define the name that we want,
we can just call this as ID. What we want
to pass here is the actual ID of the book,
which is inside@item.id. This way, when a user
clicks on Edit, it will go to the Edit razor
page. And it will also pass ID as the parameter.
Let me save this, let me stop this. Let's go back
inside the pages book list. Let's add a new razor
page called as edit. Perfect in the get handler,
we will get a parameter of ID that we just pass
it will be an integer based on this integer, we
will retrieve the book, we can use bind property.
And we can start first with private application DB
context. Because we'll have to update things.
We'll do CTO our constructor will have the
application DB context DB underscore DB is equal
to dB. Great, then we need to bind property. In
here we'll be working with just one book. So with
the public book, let's call this book will have
the getter and setter. Here we need to populate
this book object based on the database with the
ID that we received. So await will do underscore
DB dot book dot find a sink. And here we just need
to pass the ID. This is another method that we
have with our Entity Framework. Rather than why
this will be async. And task because we are using
await here. This looks good for our get method. In
the next video. Let's design the edit view and
continue working on posting or editing a book.
Now we will be working on editing the book UI. The
UI will look similar to what we have for create,
but the only difference will be the data will be
loaded. So we can go to create dot CSS HTML, and
we can copy everything right here. Do not copy the
model because model will be different. So right
here, we'll remove everything and we'll Paste
what we just copied. Rather than create new book,
it will be added book. Then if you scroll down,
we have submit here, the value will be update,
and index. This looks good. Let's run our
application and see the Edit page. Here we'll
go to book. And we'll hit the edit button. Great,
you can see the data is loaded, it's added book
and we have the Update button. If you try to hit
update, nothing happens because we have not added
the post handler. Also in the URL, you see the ID
is being passed. And this is the ASP route ID that
we added. So everything is coming along good. In
the next video, let's work on the post handler.
In this video, we'll be working on the Update
button. If we close this here, inside the Edit,
you see the form method is post and we have the
input type Submit. So on post, we need to write
a post handler in post handler will be redirecting
to page. So that's why the return type will change
that to I action result. So task of I action
result. And we'll call this on post. The first
thing we'll check here is if model state is valid.
If this is valid, then we will proceed further.
And we'll retrieve the book from the database,
because we have to edit this. Now updating can
be done in multiple ways. So one of the way is
word retrieve that from TP is equal to whatsit
await underscore DB dot book dot find a sink.
And we'll pass the book. Whoops book.id we have
the book object right here will retrieve it and
pass the ID. And we'll say book from DB dot name
is equal to book dot name. We can just copy this
and paste this two more times for ESPN and author
will copy the same here. Perfect. Once we change
this, we will say await underscore DB dot Save
Changes a synchronous, and this will update the
book object inside the database. Once we update,
this will return redirect to page. And we want to
redirect to the Index page. If the model state is
not valid, we will return and redirect back to
page. Now let's see this in action. And when we
try to run this with hit into an error, I want to
show you that error message before I show you the
solution. We go to book here. Let's try to edit
this. And we'll change the ESPN to 333. Great,
we see an error message here that object
reference is not set to an instance of an
object. This is a common error message. And it is
not self explanatory. It just says that the object
it was expecting value, but it is a null value.
Now we have to debug on what's going on. So we'll
add a debugger inside the model state variable.
And right here. Let's go back and we'll go back
here and hit the Update button. Okay, we'll see
the model state is valid. Let's continue. We'll
see the book object. And you see the ID is not
present. We have all the other values the ESPN is
the updated one, but the ID is missing. And the
reason behind that is if we hit continue here,
let me remove the debuggers ad continue again
we'll get the error that's okay. Inside the Edit.
We do not have the ID here. We have name right
here, author and ESPN. We need the ID property
inside a hidden field. So we'll do input type
is equal to hidden and we need the ASP for tag
helper for the ID so it will be book.id once you
have it and save it and if you go back. Let's go
back here and let's do a hard refresh and update
the value. This time it is updated the Cause it
finds the ID now. So always make sure that inside
edit and such fields, you have the ID or any other
properties that you want while updating must be
present in the hidden property if you do not have
that inside the input text box. Also, if you go
on Edit, we already have our validations. So if
you try to update, it gives the error message.
So with this we have completed create an edit,
let's work on Delete. In this video, we'll
be implementing the Delete. Now with delete,
you can do it the same way we did for edit and
create, you can create a new view where you will
display the details. And on the delete button, you
can do a post event. But I want to try something
new here. This time, when we hit delete, I want to
show an alert. And when the user clicks Ok, I want
to delete it too quickly from the Index page. So
for that, let's implement the pop up first, we'll
go back, I will close edit, create. And we have
the index. Right here we have the delete button,
I will add an onClick method here. And we will
save return will have a confirm box. You sure
you want to delete. If this returns true, we want
to go to a page handler on the same index page. So
we'll do a ASP page. And we'll have a handler, we
have not used this tag helper before. This time,
we want to implement a custom tag helper other
than the on get and on post, we want to call
this is delete. And when we'll be deleting, we
need to pass the ID of the book, we already know
how to pass it using ASP route. We'll call it
ID. And we'll pass item.id. Let's save this.
Let's go back and refresh. And when we hit the
delete, we now see an alert here. On cancel,
nothing happens. What should happen when they
click OK, we have to implement a delete handler
inside the Index page. So inside Solution Explorer
will open the page model. Let me stop it here. And
we will implement public async task of I action
result. Because we'll be redirecting to the same
page. And we'll implement on post delete, we'll
have an integer of ID that we will fetch because
on the index, we have the ID. This is a button.
So that's why it will be a post handler. So we
will have the on post and then the handler name
which we have defined as delete. Okay, so what
we want to do in here, we'll say variable book is
equal to, we can do it in multiple ways. First,
we can find the book. So we'll do await
underscore DB dot book dot find a sync,
and we'll pass the ID, then we'll check if book
is equal to now. That means that book does not
exist based on the ID that is passed and will
return not found. If we find the book will say
underscore DB dot book dot remove. In here, we'll
pass the book that we retrieved. And we need to
save the changes. So await underscore DB dot Save
Changes a sink. Once we remove the book, we'll
return back to the page. Or we can return back
to the Index page, making it reload. Let's save
this and let's run our application. We'll go to
book. Let's try to delete this 111. And perfect.
You can see our delete functionality is working
as expected. So with this we have completed the
CRUD operations on book list using razor syntax.
Now we have implemented the crud functionalities
that we seen before. These current functionalities
are basic HTML and dotnet. Core. How about we add
some styling and some data tables to that. So for
that, I'll be needing three things. First will be
sweet alert, because of which we'll be having
such nice alerts. Then we have toasters, for
notifications like this. And we'll be using data
tables to list all the books in such a fashionable
way that our CD ends that are needed for that.
What I will do I will have a file attached with
the CSS and the JavaScript. So you can just copy
this, go back to your code. Word starboard, will
have to go to underscored layout. On top, we
have the CSS will paste it here for data tables,
jQuery UI and toaster. And we'll also copy the J
s. And we'll scroll down to the JavaScript. And
we'll paste it right here. Now with data tables,
we need to add API calls to retrieve all of the
books in a JSON format. And we'll also add an
API call for delete. In order to add API calls,
we need to add Web API to our project. Right now,
it's only razor. So for that, we'll right click,
add a new folder. Let's call this controllers.
I'll make it plural here, controllers work right
click, add a new controller in here, we can go
with the MVC controller or the API controller,
anyone is fine. We'll just go with the MVC
controller. And we'll call this book controller.
Inside the book controller, we will need our
application DB context. So right here, we'll
have private read only application DB context,
we'll do our control dot underscore DB will have
the constructor application DB context dB, and
underscore DB is equal to dB, then we need to
implement the HTTP GET and HTTP delete. Let's just
implement the HTTP GET, we'll change this to get
all and with the get it should be HTTP GET. What
we want to do is we want to return a JSON here.
And within New, we want to pass data is equal
to underscore db dot.to list. So that way, we'll
retrieve the book. And we'll pass it back when you
call this API call. But API's are not supported
inside our startup right now. What we have right
now is only add razor pages. So in order to do
that, we'll do services dot add controller with
views. Once you add this, you will be adding the
API calls, we will also have to add that to our
middleware, especially inside the endpoints. So
we'll use endpoints dot map controllers. This way
the controller API's will be called. And right
here, we need to define the route that should
be used to call this. So the route we'll just
call is API forward slash book. And this will be
an API controller. So that way, we'll make sure
that the book controller is an API controller,
and this is the route that will be used. In such
startup. Since we have added map controller,
you can navigate to this URL and get request
will return you data from here. In this video,
we'll be making changes to the Index page that
is inside pages book list index. And right here we
have the first step that we are using right now,
I will add another div here. Let me just paste it.
And all we are doing here is column 12. We have an
oar. And I have a div with column 12. I have a
table with ID of DT lol. This is important. And
I'm just displaying the table headers. I think I
have an extra div here. There we go. Now how do we
load this table, that table will be loaded using
JavaScript. So for that, we'll add a section here.
And it will be script. We will have the script
tag here will give SRC, inside GS, I will create a
new JavaScript called book list dot j s. Let's add
that script file inside the WW root j s. We'll add
a new item. We can search for Java here. And let's
call this book list. And then let's start working
on the JavaScript here. So we'll have the variable
data table here and fill us the dollar document
dot ready function. We'll add a function in here
And we'll call load data table. Let's add this
load data table. So we can just copy this. And
we'll add a function here, paste that. And what
we want to do here is we'll load the variable data
table, we want to load it on index, we have the DT
load, we can copy this will retrieve that hash,
and DT load. That way we'll call data table. This
data table has been included with the JavaScript
reference that you added with data tables. So dot
data table will populate a data table on DT load.
In here, we have few things, we need to make an
AJAX call to our API. So for that, right here, we
need to define the URL and URL is forward slash
API, forward slash book, then we need a type here,
because this will be a get request, followed by
data type, and data type will be JSON. After the
AJAX call, we need to define all the columns that
we have to display. So right here, we will have
columns, and this will be an array. So right here,
the first one will do data. And what is the
name of the column that is name itself, comma,
we want to say what width it should occupy. So
that will be in percentage. So we can do 30%. We
can copy this and paste it two more time. We have
author here, and we have our ESPN, make sure it
follows camel casing. If inside book the variable,
you had his name, right here you had named ABC,
then what you would do is right here, this will be
named ABC, the first one should be a lower case,
we only have named so everything is the lower
case right here. After this, the last column we
want is edit and delete buttons. So in the last
one, the data fields that we want is the ID,
because when we edit or delete, we need to pass
the ID of the book. So we'll have ID here. And we
will have a render, because we want to render
two buttons here. So this will be a function,
and we will pass the ID. So that's why we'll pass
the data, which has the ID. In here, what we want
to do is we want to return a div with two buttons.
Since this will be a multi line statement, we can
use the tilde sign and break up the statements.
tilde sign is available right next to the one on
your keyboard. Here we start with Dave, give it
a class of text center. And we'll add the ending
div. Since there is no IntelliSense, you have to
do this manually. Then you have an anchor tag,
we'll do x ref, what we want to do is we want to
add an edit page. And right here, we will have
booklist forward slash edit, and we need to pass
the ID. So Id is equal to dollar. And in here we
have the data. So that way we'll be passing the
data which has the ID of the book. We'll give it
a classes of btn btn success and text white, we
will also give it a style of cursor of pointer
and we'll give it a width of 100 pixels. This
looks good for our anchor tag. And then in the
next line, we will add the added button will close
the anchor tag here. And we can copy this anchor
tag because we want another one for delete. So
right here, I'll add some space ampersand nbsp
and we'll paste it one more time. On delete, we do
not want to go to any of the URL. So we'll leave
the extract out right now. We'll have the classes
of btn danger and we'll add an onClick but we'll
do that later. I'll just make it delete and we'll
have the closing div. So this looks good. Then,
in this render with an ad with here and We'll
make it 30%. Outside of this array that we had
four columns, we'll do comma. And I will add
language here. In here, I do empty tables. If
there is no data, I want to display no data
found. We'll do what columns are here, and
we'll give it a width of 100%. Everything should
be in double quotes, like this. So with this,
we have our data table in place. Let me save this.
And we need to run our application. To see this in
action. We already added the code inside the Index
page. So if we go and book we will see two tables.
Now. The first one you can see right here, and
here is the later one. But here the JavaScript is
not getting called. And I guess that's because we
have a mistake with the file name here. It should
be booklists. JavaScript. Let's enter that and hit
the Run button again. We get one book. And great,
we see our data table in place with the number of
entries we have pagination, sorting, and search by
default. Here, the stylings has not been applied.
Let me go back and take a look. We forgot an equal
to here. Let's save this, go back and refresh.
And perfect. We see everything is coming along.
Let me just reduce the size here. I'll make it
20. And we can make this 40. And width that will
make it 70 pixels, and both the places that
save it and refresh, and perfect. This looks
much aligned. When you hit the Edit, it will take
you to the Edit page. And if you click on delete,
right now, nothing happens. In this video, let's
work on the Delete. On delete, we want to display
a nice alert here and on. Okay, we want to delete
it directly but using an API call. So for that,
we'll have to go back and we'll have to add an
API call inside our book controller. So we will
add an HTTP delete here. And this will be public
I action result, delete. Here, we'll be getting
an ID that we have to delete. We'll say variable
book from DB is equal to underscore DB dot pub
dot first or default. And we can say u goes to
a u.it is equal equal to ID. Now right here,
it is always good to be consistent. So we will do
a sync, and it will be task of I action result.
And we will do await here. And we have the
tool list a sync, we'll have to do a control.to
include Entity Framework core firstar default,
we have the async method in here. So we'll do
control dot oops, there we go. And we'll use
await. We have a sync task of I action result,
then we'll check here if both from DB is equal
equal to Now in this case, we will return JSON.
And we'll return new. This time, we want to make
sure success is false, because we did not receive
any book. Karma will also display a message error
while deleting. If we found that book with the
underscore DB dot, dot remove, and we'll say awake
underscore DB dot Save Changes. It's synchronous,
then we'll return back the JSON. This time we'll
have a new and success will be true. And we'll
have a message which will be delete successful.
So this looks good. Here we are getting an error.
Let's do a control dot whoops and that is because
we did not pass the object that we had to remove,
which is booked from dB. Perfect. So the Delete
method looks good. All we have to do is inside the
JavaScript, we need to add a function to delete.
Let's do that in the next video. In this video,
we'll be adding a function to delete and call our
API. So right here where we have the Delete tag,
we will add an onClick method. So right
here, we will say on click is equal to,
let's call a function, delete. And we'll pass our
API call here. So we'll have API book. And then
we need to pass the ID is equal to, we'll do plus,
and we have the dollar data. And then at the end,
we will be adding the Delete function. So we'll
add function, delete will receive the URL here.
And we need to display sweet alert. So we'll
do swa L, and will add the properties like
title. Are you sure karma will have text. Once
deleted, you will not be able to recover. We can
have an icon here of warning. And we can have a
danger mode here to drill. These are just some
of the properties that you can use. And we'll be
using Ajax here. So we'll use them. And in here,
we'll say we'll delete this will be the response.
Based on this we'll have a function. Here,
we'll check if we'll delete. That means if user
selected Yes, they want to delete, we will make an
AJAX call here. AJAX call, we will have the type
of delete, we're going to have the URL, which we
have right here inside the parameters, we'll do
a comma. On success, what we want you to do is
we want a function with data that we retrieved.
And we want to display a toaster notification. So
we will do toaster.we have this success here.
And we want to display message. Inside here,
I need an if condition. And we'll check if this
is success or not. If this is successful, we'll
display torstar dot message. And we will say data
table. This should be message. And that is because
if we go to controller, we have message right
here. And then we'll do data table dot Ajax dot
reload. In the else block here, we want to display
an error. So I can copy this and paste it. And
this will be error. This looks good. We'll add the
two semi colon. And now let's run our application.
We'll go to book. Let's try to delete. Great, we
see the notification here, you can click outside,
or you can hit the Delete. And if we hit Delete
here, it doesn't do anything. But actually,
if you refresh the data is deleted, we have
some issues with the display. So right here,
let's see the toaster. This should not be message
it should be data dot message, because we have
that inside the data object. And also, if you go
to book controller, I have a mistake with success
spelling here. Let's run it and see everything
in action. Let's go to book and create new book.
Let's hit the Delete. Okay, great. We see a
nice toaster notification. And then if we just
scroll back inside the sweet alert IP, add another
property here buttons is equal to true. And after
that if we go back and we go to book, create new,
let's add one. Create and then if we click Delete,
we see ok and cancel. So that way we have
everything working. Now here I have had request
from students many times that the Create view
will look similar to what we have for our edit.
So why not combine both of them in one view or
one razor page? So that can be done? Absolutely.
Let me stop the application and I'll show you how
that is possible. Usually the name first Each page
is absurd, because it is a combination of update
and insert. So we can just copy the edit that we
have. Or let me just add a new view, because when
we copy, we have to make sure many things needs to
be updated like model. So the page name, it will
be absurd. And this looks good. Let's add that
inside our ProQuest. It will be similar to edit
page, but there will be modifications, let's first
copy everything that we have inside edit, not the
model. So we'll copy this, and we'll close that,
we'll go to our absurd page. And we'll paste it
right here. Let's save this. Let's go to the Edit
Page model. And we'll copy everything inside the
model from application DB context. And we'll just
leave two brackets at the end. Whoops, we'll start
after the two brackets. And there we go. Let's
copy this. Let's close this go to the absurd. And
let's remove this and paste it right here. Now
what will happen within absurd is it will be used
for creating as well as updating redo control dot
here, because of which inside the Edit model, this
will be upset model actually. And because of which
the ad it is possible, there won't be any ID if
this is used for create. So that's why we have to
use a nullable integer so that Id can be now then
inside the get what we have to do is we'll say
book is equal to new book. Once we have that we'll
check here if Id is equal to now. If Id is no,
that means that this is for create. So we will
return back to the page. If that is not now we
will continue here. Because of this we need to
change from task to I action result. If the ID
is not now that means we have to retrieve the book
from the database. So book is equal to underscore
DB dot book dot first dot default a sink will have
to do ctrl.to include Entity Framework core, we'll
do a weight here. And we'll say you goes to a u.id
is equal equal to the ID, we will find the book
and after we find this we'll check if and we'll
say book is equal equal to Now if that is true,
then we'll return not found. If this is not the
case, we will return back to the page. Now when
we are retrieving from the database, you can use
first or default async or you can use fine async
any of those methods will work. So this way, we
will handle it for both create. This will be for
create. And this will be for update. So the same
handler will be using for both the scenarios. That
looks good for the get handler, then inside the
post handler, we will do the same. We will check
first if the model state is valid or not. If it's
not valid, we'll return back then if it is valid,
what we will do is right here, we'll check if
book.id is equal equal to zero. If this is true,
then underscore DB dot book dot add. And we'll
add book. Else what we will do is underscore
db.book.we also have update method. In here, we'll
pass the book. So previously, you saw other way of
updating the book by retrieving it from the
database. And here we're using directly the
update method. So when should you use the previous
one versus this one. This update should be used if
you want to update every property of the book.
But if you only want to update two properties
within use the way that we used inside the Edit
page. Once we do this, we'll save the changes.
And we'll redirect back to the page. So perfect.
This looks good for our upset cat as well as post
handlers. In the next video, let's fix the update
view or the razor page and we should be good. In
the last video, we fixed the handlers for absurd.
In this video, let's work on the razor page. The
things that we have to do differently in create an
edit is the title here. So in here we can use the
razor see index and we can check if model.book.id
does not equal to zero. If this is true, we will
display edit, else we will display create we will
copy this condition and we will have to do the
same for the ID in the hidden property will add f
model.book.id does not equal to zero, then we will
have the ID else we do not need it in the Create.
Lastly if you scroll down we need to do the same
for the pattern. So inside the input type we can
just replace this with button we can say type is
equal to submit and we can add the same classes
btn btn primary form control and we'll paste what
we had before for ad model. So if this is not
now then we will display as update else we will
display create let's save this and with this the
absurd view or the razor page looks good. How do
we test this we can go to our booklists.js and if
we scroll up so we'll change this to absurd here
and we'll also change the Create so far that we'll
have to go to the index and then if we scroll up
right here we'll change this to absurd. Let's save
this and run our application. And right here we'll
go to book and hit Create new book we are on
the absurd. Let's try to create one work great
this work. And if we click on the Edit here, it
takes us to the absurd. Let's try to update this
perfect that is working. If I click on edit in the
first one, it takes you to the Edit page. Here we
can also add a new text box so that we'll have
both of them so I can just copy this and paste
it one more time. Next will be create and create
new book and observed whoops I think I switched
that around fact me paste this will save this go
back and refresh I have one more thing I have to
change this to six and perfect now we see create
new book takes us to create add absurd takes you
to the absurd, but everything is exactly the same.
So with this, we complete the absurd and how you
can combine both of the logic inside a single
razor page. Now that we have completed Razer
project, it's time to explore the other type of
application, which is an MVC project. So in this
section, we'll create our next project, which will
be the book list. But in that we will use MVC,
we will take a look at how routing is different in
MVC as compared to razor pages, and we'll see the
new folders with the MVC project. So let's get
started with that from the next video. What we
have to do is we need to create project for our
MVC crud operation. We'll start Visual Studio
2019 and we'll select create a new project. In
here we'll select ASP. NET Core web application
and hit the Next button. Then we need the name
of our project. So we'll call it boquist MVC,
and you'll select a location. I'll change
the location to where I want and I hit the
Create button. That being said, we need to select
options for our project. Now in here we'll select
ASP dotnet core 3.1. And we'll be selecting MVC
for our project. We can change the authentication
to select individual users account. But with
that many things comes configured. So I do not
want to start with that route. We'll go with no
authentication and we'll add database objects
manually. That way we will learn those concepts
that being said once everything is aligned here,
let's hit the Create button. Perfect. So with this
The project has been created with model views and
controller and this is slightly different to what
we have seen with razor pages. As we saw from the
architecture we will have controllers which will
have the logic models will have the data and view
will be the UI component. So we have all of those
three folders right here. And the other things
are common like www root dependencies properties,
app settings, program.cs and startup.cs. The only
difference is inside startup.cs class file. If you
scroll down, inside configure services, we do not
have the Add razor pages, we have ADD controllers
with views. Also, if you scroll down route here,
inside the routing, and endpoints, they have
registered map controller route, because we
need controller actions and even areas in advanced
courses. So these are the only differences between
MVC and razor pages inside the setup files. Of
course, the working of controller models and views
is completely different. And we'll understand that
in the upcoming videos. In this video, let's take
a look at the folder structure in an MVC project.
The three main folders that are different our
model views and controller right here. The first
folder is the controller's folder. And in here we
have the main logic of our web application. Here
we have the home controller, one rule that we have
is the controller name will be home, and it should
match exactly with a folder inside the view. So if
we have the views for homepage, the controller
name will be home followed by a controller
keyword. inside the home controller, you can see
we have methods here. And all of these methods are
called actions. So the terminal logic to remember
is within controller we will have actions. The
next folder that we have is the models folder.
Here as of now we only have error view model.
But as we proceed, we will be adding new models
here. Any table that we have in our database,
we will have a corresponding class as a model in
this folder. We will also have view models which
are a combination of multiple models, and we will
discuss them in detail when we need them. Finally,
we have the views folder. In here if we expand
we have the shared folder, in which we have the
underscore layout and validation scripts partial,
which we discussed. And we have view imports and
view start. The new folder is the home folder.
And in here we have index and privacy. And one
thing to notice is inside the home controller
we have actions called index and privacy. So
here whatever data is being passed will be the
model for these two pages or views. If we add a
new controller here, let's say Brogan controller,
then we will have to add a new folder here called
pregame to add the views for that new controller.
You will understand this more once we start
coding. But I wanted to give you a brief overview
of all the three folders that we have. Now let's
just understand how routing works in typical MVC.
asp dotnet routing is a pattern matching system,
which enables you to match the incoming request to
a particular MVC action defined in a controller.
When ASP dotnet routing engine receives a request
at runtime, it finds the match against the URL
pattern defined in the route table. If any match
is found, then it forwards that request to the
controller. Otherwise, it will return a 404 not
found message when we will create a new ASP. NET
Core MVC application routes are already added to
the project. If we switch back to our application.
And if we go on startup.cs, right here, where it's
adding controllers with view to our pipeline. And
when we see the middlewares, we have first the
app dot use routing. And we have the app dot
use endpoints. Now you can keep endpoints or you
can also use the routing without the endpoints in
versions one and two of ASP dotnet core. This was
a part of MVC. But now it is a separate piece of
middleware to make routing available to all the
middlewares and not just MVC. So that's why we
see app dot use routing on top. And then we have
app dot use endpoints at the bottom endpoint is a
URL where incoming request will end up processing
by the middleware. If you have used MVC, before,
you know that you have to specify the routes for
this. And right here we are specifying a default
route in which if nothing is defined, it will
look for the home controller, and it will call
the index action inside that. Now, ASP dotnet core
is not just MVC, it supports different technology,
which uses routes, like razor pages, signaler, and
MVC. And the routing is different for each one of
them. All of this tag uses middleware stack
registers the endpoints. So if you see here,
right now, we only have the MVC endpoint that is
registered, because that is what we'll be using
in this application. In previous version of ASP
dotnet, core routing was embedded in MVC. But that
cannot work anymore. Since we have more than one
technology, which uses different types of routing.
First we will do is we will add user routing,
which will make the selected endpoint choices
available to all the middlewares that follows
after that. And when we will do use endpoints at
that point, we'll be able to register and execute
the endpoints. In lambda expression, we have
several extension methods to register endpoints.
One of them you can see here is map controller
route. Let's try to run our application and see
what happens. In the URL, we do not have anything
defined, it's just the domain name, or localhost
and the port number. In that case, if we go back,
it should go to Home controller index action.
So if we go on Solution Explorer inside home,
let me add a debugger inside index and privacy.
Let's go back and press Enter Here, you can see it
goes to the index section of the home controller.
And when we continue, it will load the view for
that. So the view if you go to Solution Explorer
views home, we have the index view, right here,
we have a welcome text. And that is what we
see inside the UI. When we click on privacy,
the link goes to home controller privacy action
method, and then it should render the page
inside the home folder in views and privacy
page right here. So if we do continue, here,
you can see home privacy is loaded. So the first
one here is the controller name. And the latest
one is the action method. If you have not defined
anything, it goes to the index action by default.
So if you just define home, it goes to the home
controller and loads the index action method. If
you do not define home as well, it will go again
to the home controller index action method. And
that is because you have defined that in endpoint
to use as a default controller and action method.
So this was a brief overview of routing in MVC.
And we'll continue exploring this more when we
start building our application. Now that we have
the MVC application created, in this section, we
will work on the same booklist project to perform
all the CRUD operations, but we will use our MVC,
we'll be adding models, views and controllers, and
we'll see how everything comes together. Let's get
started with that from the next video. Now that
we have a brief overview of our MVC project,
it's time to perform CRUD operations on the bucket
list again. So the first thing we will do is we
will add model for our book. So we'll add a new
class, we'll call it book. And in here, we will
add all the properties. First will be the ID. So
we can use key data annotation, and we'll call it
prop integer ID. Next, we'll use the snippet prop
tap twice with a string name. We can copy this and
paste this two more times. Name property, let me
make it required. And the other one, I'll change
this to author and I ESPN. This looks good for our
model. Once we have model in place, we need to add
this to database. So there are multiple things
that we have to do to add it to the database.
First in the models, we'll add our DB context
class, which we will call application DB context.
In here, we need the constructor. So CTR and
within the constructor, we need to pass the DB
context options. We'll do control dot here, here,
we need to include the package for Microsoft dot
Entity Framework core will find an installed
the latest version. You can do this by going
to the new get package solution, but I want to
do it right here directly. Here, we'll pass the
application DB context. And we'll have options.
And we need to pass it to the base class, the
same options. Once we have that the application DB
context should inherit from DB context. Now that
application DB context is looking good, what we
need is we need to add our book to the database.
So whenever we have to add a table, we'll add
that property inside the application DB context.
So we'll do prop. This will be of type DB set
on book. And let me call this books. Perfect.
This looks good for our application DB context.
And this is exactly what we did in razor pages
as well. Then the next thing is to add connection
string, and to get the connection string inside
configure services in startup.cs. So we'll go to
app settings dot JSON. And in here, let me paste
the connection string. Now remember, one thing
that the server name, you have to double check. So
make sure if you're using this connection string,
copy the server name, go to your SQL Server, paste
it here, you just need one backward slash and try
to connect. As long as you're able to connect,
you can use the same connection string, the
project, let me call this vocalist MVC. For the
database name, we have trusted connection to true
and multiple active results search to true. Great,
so this looks good. And the connection string has
been added in app settings dot JSON exactly like
we did increase our pages. The last thing that
we have to do is we need to configure startup.cs
to use that connection string. So within the
Configure services, we will add services dot
add DB context. In here, it will be on application
DB context, we'll have to do a control dot here to
include models. And we need to pass the options
for SQL Server. So options goes to options. use
SQL server will have to install a new nougat
package. Let me do control dot here again. And
I do not see that nougat package here. So what I
will do is I will just go to Tools, nougat package
manager solution. And we'll search for SQL Server.
We have the package, which is Microsoft dot Entity
Framework, core dot SQL Server, let's install the
latest version here. Perfect it is installed. Now
if we go back, and if we do Ctrl dot, we'll see
the using statement for Microsoft, that Entity
Framework core. And once we do that, there we go.
Here, we need to parse connection string from the
configuration. So we'll do configuration.we have
a get connection string here. And we need to pass
the name inside our app settings, which is default
connection. We'll copy that and paste it right
here. Let me break it in a new line. There we go
looks much better. This looks good for all the
configuration that we have to do. But we also want
to add the waser compiler package. So right here,
let me add the razor compilation package actually
will search for runtime compilation, there we
go and install the package. This package we are
installing so that if the application is running,
and we change anything in the view, and we
refresh, we don't have to restart the application.
Whoops, there we go. And right here, we'll do add
razor runtime compilation. Great. This is exactly
what we did with razor pages as well. That's why
I'm not spending much time here. Once you do this,
let's add a migration. So we'll go to Tools nougat
package manager console will add migration add
book to dB And here we see an error with the
migration. That's because if we go to Tools,
nougat package manager, we have to install
package for Entity Framework tools. So if you
search for Entity Framework, tattoos will install
the Microsoft dot Entity Framework core dot tools
to our project. Once that is installed, then add
migration should work. Awesome. Let's go back to
package manager and hit the command one more time.
This time it is already building the project it
was successful, and it adds a migration right
here. Great Migration looks good. Let's update
the database to push our model to database, it
will first create that database, and then it will
add the tables. Great. Let's go back to make sure
it's working. We'll go to database in SQL Server,
we have the new database. in there, we have our
table called books. And great we have all the
columns as we wanted. Once we add the model to our
database, next thing, let's go to our master page,
which is underscored layout. And let's add
a link for a new controller for our book,
we'll copy the ally here, the new controller,
let's call it books controller. And in there,
we'll have an index action. We'll call this
as book list. And let's add a new controller.
Inside controllers, we have the home controller,
in here, we'll add a new controller, we'll go
with the empty controller for MVC. And we'll
call this as books controller with the name of
the controller controller has to be pre has to be
added at the end. So whatever name you give before
controller will be the name of that controller.
In this case, it will be books controller, great,
our controller is added. And in here we have the
index action. Let's try to run our application and
see what happens when you click on the link.
Since we already have index action. In here,
it will take you to books controller index action,
but since we do not have any view, it will give
an error that the view index was not found. It
tried to look inside views books index dot CSS,
HTML. And since it did not find it there, it also
looked inside the shared folder. So even though
we have the action method for index, we do not
have the view. To add a view, what you can do is
inside our views folder, you can create a new
folder with the same name as your controller,
which is books. And in there, you will have to add
index view, you can do that in Solution Explorer,
or you can just right click on index and click Add
view. Here we'll go with the empty view. And we do
not want it to be a partial view. Partial view is
something that you want when you will be consuming
that inside some other view. But in this case
index will have a page by itself. That being said,
we'll select Use a layout page because we want
the same header and footer for our index page as
well. Let's hit add here. Perfect. Now if you run
the application, and if you navigate on the link,
you will see the word index, as you can see
right here. So we click here. And great,
we see our view in action. Let's continue working
here in the next video. Now in this video, since
we have our application running with the index, I
want to install few third party tools. First is a
sweet alert that I want to display nice alerts in
our web page. Next is a toaster notification. And
in here, if we go to toaster j s, we go to demo.
And when you click Show toast, you see we have
nice toaster notifications here. We'll use this
when we delete our poke. So we'll use toaster
and the last one is data tables. Here we get
sorting functionalities, number of pages, paging
functionality and search right out of the box.
So we'll be using all three of them. Now you can
go here and get the CD ends or I will have that
attached with The lecture. So let me open that
up. And within the attachments, you will see CSS
underscore js, we will copy the CSS. Let's go back
to our application. And in here, let me close,
everything will be adding that in our master page.
Because once we add in the master page, it will be
accessible in all the other pages. So on top here,
we will be adding the CSS. And when we scroll
down, we have to add the JavaScript. So copy that
and paste it right here. So perfect, this looks
good. And we have added all three of them to our
project. Now, since our application is already
running, in our razor pages with index, we use
data tables, and we added a JavaScript will do the
same in this MVC project as well. The JavaScript
will have the exact same functionalities.
Before we work on the JavaScript, let's
work and create the action methods inside our
controller. Let's do that in the next video. Now,
within our booklists MVC project, we want to work
on our controller, which is the books controller.
Let me open up the razor project that we built. In
here, I have pulled up the razor project in which
we added the API calls to get all of the book,
as well as to delete a book, this course will be
exactly the same. So we can copy this. And let me
close that project. We'll switch back to our MVC
project. And within our books controller, since
those are API calls, we will create a region here,
and we'll call it API calls, I will enter the
region as well. And between that we will paste
the code that we copied. Now, first thing in
controller when we have to Access database,
we need the application DB context. So we'll
have private read only application DB context,
we will do a control.to include using booklist MVC
dot models. And we'll call this underscore dB. We
need to get this using dependency injection. So
we'll create a constructor here. And we'll have
the application DB context dB. And we'll do
underscore DB is equal to dB. This you must
be familiar by now that we need to do this to get
the DB context using dependency injection. Then
if we scroll down rather than book, what we have
is books inside our application DB context. Then,
for two lists and async, we'll do ctrl.to include
Microsoft dot Entity Framework core will make
books in all the places other than that everything
will be seen forget all and delete API's. Once we
have that, then inside index, when we return back
to the view, we do not want to pass anything here,
because we will be loading this view using the API
call right here with the help of data table. So
let me go to the View. And in here, we need to
add us for our JavaScript. That being said the
JavaScript will be exactly the same with one
or two modifications as compared to our razor
code. So I have that in the attachments as well,
which is exactly the same as what we have in the
razor project. We will copy this, go to Solution
Explorer, ww root j s, we will add a new item. And
this will be a JAVA script. And we'll call this
book list dot j s. let me paste the code that we
copied. All we have to change here is URLs. All
that was changed here was the URLs. Here we had
API forward slash books inside razor pages, but
in MVC, we do not have that we are in the books
controller. And if we want to call any action
method in here, all we need is the controller
name, followed by the action name. So the API
calls are get all and delete because of which
if we go to publish.js to get all of the books we
are calling books, which is the controller name,
followed by the action name, which is get all that
will retrieve all of the books Then when we have
to edit the book, we are calling the controller.
And then right here you see an action name, which
is absurd. We do not have this action yet, but
we will add this in the upcoming videos. Lastly,
you see inside the Delete here, we are calling
the books controller, and then the Delete action
method with an ID, which we are passing, which
is the ID of the book. So if we go to books
controller, we have the Delete action. And here
we are expecting an ID. So you can see the chain
is exactly similar as we did inside the razor
pages. That being said, our JavaScript is in
place and our controller API are in place, all
we have to do is we need to add the table and
call our JavaScript in index. Let's do that in
the next video. In this video, let's modify the
index view and see how it looks. We do not need a
model in this because we'll be loading everything
using data tables. With additive give it a class
of container and row and give it padding zero and
margin zero. Within this main div, we'll add a div
with class of column sex. And we'll have our title
here. We'll use bootstrap class for text info. And
we'll call this book rest. After this column six,
let me add another div, give it a class of column
six. And here I want the button rather than six
here, let me make it column three, and offset
it by three. And we will add a button or a link
here. Now this link, I want us to redirect to an
absurd page where we can create a new book. So
in order to redirect, just like we had ASP page
inside razor pages in MVC, we have ASB action.
Let's say if you want to redirect to action in a
different controller, we also have ASP controller.
So here you can write books controller. in there,
we have the absurd action, which we will add,
then we'll add some bootstrap classes btn btn.
info, and we'll give it form control. We'll also
make it text off white, there we go. And in here,
I will display add new book. Now in this case,
since the upset action will also be added inside
the books controller, it is okay if you do not
write this. So this is optional, but I will leave
it there. After this Dev, let me add another div.
And this time, I'll give it a class of column
12. For our main table, along with column 12,
I will add a border and I will give padding three.
Then here we want our main table, we'll give it
an ID that we have inside purplish.js, which is DT
underscore load will copy and pasted will add some
bootstrap classes like table, table striped, and
table border whoops, table bordered. Along with
that, I also add a style to give it a width of
100%. Perfect. Here we will add t head for the
headings in which we'll add the table row will
have the th tag, we want to display name, author,
isbm and buttons to edit and delete. So I ESPN
author, and the last one would have the buttons
to edit and delete. That being said, we need a
reference to request dot j s. So we'll add section
scripts. In here we'll add the script tag, add an
SRC for Java Script book list dot j s. Once you
do all of that, that's one our application and
see how things look. Let's go to ProQuest here
and great it's loading and no data found. That's
because we have not added any book yet. But we
can see the data table is loading as expected. If
you click on add new book, it will give an error
because we have not added that action method or
that view. In the next video. Let's work on the
absurd. Get Action method and the view. In this
video, let's work and create an absurd get action
method. Absurd view will be used for two places,
one to edit a book and one to create a book. Based
on that, sometimes it will retrieve an ID, if it
is for edit. If it is for create, there won't be
any ID. So we can copy this index, paste it here.
And we'll call this action method as absurd.
In here parameter, it can receive an ID or it
cannot. So we'll make this a nullable parameter.
That being said, Now you need a book object with
absurd. So we can add that book object right here,
we'll do Prop, it will be a book object. And we'll
call this book. Now we can use find property here.
And once you find that property on post, you
won't have to retrieve that it will automatically
be binded. That being said, inside the view here,
first, let's initialize the book is equal to a new
book. And then we will check here if it is equal
to Now if this is null, that means this is for
a create request. And we will return back to the
view the book object, which is just a new object.
If this is not the case, that means this is for
an update. If someone wants to update a book, we
need to retrieve all the data for that book from
database. And we have to display that. So we'll
retrieve that input here from db.we have the books
object or model, and we just want to retrieve one
book. So we can use first dot default here, and
we'll say u goes to a u.it is equal equal to the
ID that we retrieve right here. After that, we
can check here, if book is equal equal to Now,
if this is not, that means there is no book
in the database. And we will just return not
found. If we find that book will return back to
the upset view. But we will populate the Book
which We have retrieved from the database. So
the view will expect a book regardless of if it
is used for create or update. This looks good for
the absurd cat action method. In the next video,
let's add the absurd view. In this video, let
me add the absurd view, we can right click on
the action method. And we'll click Add view. This
looks good. Let's add this. Now the opposite view
first thing what will be the model, if we take
a look at the books controller, we are passing
a book object to the view. So that will be the
model. So we'll define model. It is book list MVC
dot models dot book, we'll add a br and we'll add
heading here give it a class of text info. Here
we want to display edit book or create book based
on the request. If we go back to our controller,
if Id is now then we pass the book object with
a null ID. So if Id is null, then it is a create
request. So right here now will be zero. So we can
check at and we'll say if model.id does not equal
to zero. If it is not zero, then display edit,
else will just display create. Along with that
we want to display book. This way the single line
will serve both create an edit book to display the
title. We will add br here and we'll add mean to
give it a class of border and we'll add container
we will give it a style for padding of 30 pixels.
Within here, let me add a form tag and we'll give
method of post. So that whenever a user submits
the button, it will go to the post action method
for absurd inside the books controller. Here you
can also define the action method as absurd. But
since we are on the absurd, if you did not define
this, that will also work. If it was some other
action method as compared with the name then
you would have to define it but in this case
we are good. Now when we will be posting it, we
will need the ID if the ID is not now, so we'll
add an add a fear. And we'll check if model.id is
not zero, then I want to show that Id in an hidden
property. So input type is equal to hidden ASP
four will be the ID. Then just like razor pages,
we want validations here. So we'll add class of
text danger. And we'll use ASP Validation Summary
for model only. Then we'll start displaying our
property in class of form group and row. And in
each one of them, we'll add a div give it a class
of column three. First, we want to display label
with ASP for this will be named. And we'll add a
div give it a class of column six in here, we want
the input type. So input ASP for tag helper. This
will be for name of the book, and we'll give it a
class of form control. Along with that, we will
add a span with ASP validation for for our name,
and we'll give it a class of text danger. This
looks good for our first property. Let me copy
this and paste it two more times. Let me do it
three times actually, after name, we have author
will copy this and paste it here. And we have ESPN
will copy and paste it here. Once we complete the
ESPN, next will be button to create or update
and a link to go back to the page. So we'll have
column three here, let me also make it an offset
of three. And this one will be three. In here,
let me have a pattern of type Submit. Since we are
in a form, this will be good. We'll add btn btn,
primary and form control. Then what we want
to display in button is we want the same logic
that we had right here. So we can copy this,
and we'll paste it here. Rather than edit,
we will display update or create. Next is a
link to go back. So right here, we can display
an anchor tag with the tag helper ESP action.
If we click this action, we want to go to the
index section of books controller. Since we are
already in books controller, it's okay if you do
not write ASP controller here. And just ASP action
is sufficient. We'll add some bootstrap classes
here btn success and form control and will display
back to list. That being said, let's save this.
And let's run our application. In here, if you go
to book list, and we do not have any data, let's
add a new book and hit Create. Great, we have the
validations. But when we hit it goes back. We do
not want that. So for that we will add the scripts
right here. So we'll add section scripts. And in
here, we will add partial name off. If we go to
our shared we have validation scripts partial
that need to rename and copy this. And we'll paste
it right here. Let's run our application and give
this another try. Let's go to book list. Let's
try to add one add create this time it did not do
a postback and displayed the validation, we will
fill in some details and hit the Create Nothing
will happen. The reason is we have not configured
the post action method for absurd. Let's do that
in the next video. Now that we have added the
absurd view, what will happen when we hit a button
with all the details. For that we need to add an
absurd post action method. So we can just copy
this and we'll paste it one more time. This time
we need to mention that this is an HTTP POST. This
time we need to mention that this is an HTTP POST.
And with post methods, we have to use validate
anti forgery token to use the inbuilt security to
prevent some attacks. That being said in absurd.
Right here you can use book And we'll retrieve
the object like this when you submit the form,
but if you go to the top right here you are
using bind property, because of which you do
not need this, you can directly access the book
object that we have inside our controller. Now,
within the absurd, what is the first thing that
you should check, we should check if model state
is valid or not. So, if model state is valid, only
then proceed further. If it is valid, then we will
check here, if both.id is equal equal to zero,
if this is zero, this means it is a create. And
we will do underscore DB dot books dot add. And
we will add the book object there. Else it is for
an update. So we'll do underscore db.books.we have
an update method in here. And we just need to pass
the object that has to be updated, it will update
this based on the ID inside this book object. Once
all of the system, we need to do underscore DB
dot Save Changes to push all the changes to our
database. Once the changes have been pushed, we
want to return back in razor pages we were using
redirect to page in MVC, we will use redirect
to action, and we can redirect to the index
action. So what it will do is after it saves the
changes, it redirects to the index action here,
and it will load all of the books again from
the database. This looks good. Let's run this
and give this a try. Let's go to book list here,
add a new book, we will fill in some details and
hit the Create button. Great. You can see our
data tables is also working with the new book.
Let's try to update this. You can see create
an edit both the functionalities are working
as expected. The only thing that is remaining
is delete here. Now when you click on delete,
you'll see a nice sweet alert. And if you click OK
here, it should delete the book. And it displays
nice toaster notification. You can see our create,
edit, as well as delete are working as expected.
Now with this you can see how we can perform CRUD
operations on booklist using an MVC project. And
this is just the beginning. That is much more to
explore in ASP. NET Core. Whether you go with MVC
or razor pages, what we just learned is the tip of
the iceberg. So if you're interested in learning
more about MVC or razor pages, I have many more
in depth courses in which we will be building real
world application. But that's all we had for this
course and good luck with your future projects.